in a new report from the New York Post
Facebook has been spying on
conservatives people who question the
2020 election or otherwise had
subversive messages and they were
sending it to the FBI
that's crazy
um I can't believe it like outright just
spying but I you know I can believe it
yeah I think it's silly to say you
couldn't believe it we know that they
were also
instructing these big tech companies the
federal government was who to ban asking
why people weren't being banned so they
were effectively at this point acting as
an instrument to the government ladies
and gentlemen y'all better start laying
on the lawsuits because now we have
evidence that they're acting at the
passive government now we got
constitutional violations the door has
been opened we'll see how things play up
we'll see how it goes we got that story
which is particularly huge considering
what's going on with you know the FBI
the raids people on people like Bannon
and Michael Lindell Mike Lindell is
suing the government and then we have
probably just one of the funniest
stories Ron DeSantis sends illegal
immigrants to Martha's Vineyard yes yeah
I would love to go to Martha's Vineyard
it is beautiful Barack Obama lives there
everybody's really excited they're
pissed off and Kareem Jean-Pierre has
one of the funniest quotes I've ever
heard she said something like it was
cruel to send people to Martha's
Vineyard and I'm just like what is what
is this he gave him like an all-expense
paid vacation basically pretty great
well you know I I he he hit the nail on
the head with the hammer with that one
so Bravo Ronda Santos we're gonna talk
about all of that before we get started
my friends head over to timcast.com
become a member
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to the timcast IRL
uncensored after hours show we're gonna
have one of those after hours not so
family friendly uncensored shows coming
up at 11 PM tonight you don't want to
miss it so head over to Tim guest on
click timcast.com click that join us
button don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends
and let me tell you something a lot of
people have been pointing out that
they're not getting notifications for
the show currently and uh it's see it's
like you know right around two months
before the election all of a sudden
people weren't getting notifications
something changed we don't know what and
you know how we know
our website has an automatic feature
that pulls the that embeds the live
stream player on the home page of the
website and for some reason on the same
time people notice they weren't getting
notifications the link wasn't working
the embed stopped working too so it
really does seem like there is something
going on there
don't know what interesting though if
you would like to help out share the
video take the URL and you guys be the
notifications if they're not going to
put out notifications for whatever
reason then you guys can take the link
right above copy it and paste it on
every single social media platform and
be 10 times more powerful than whatever
it is they thought they were going to
take away from us
that would be awesome and would really
do appreciate it joining us today to
talk about this and more we've got Ryan
Walters
thank you for having me I'm excited to
be here tonight who are you good sir I
am currently the Oklahoma Secretary of
Education so I work for the governor in
the governor's office there and I'm
running for State superintendent
Oklahoma we've got some crazy left-wing
ideology being pushed in our school so
we're going to be a state that fights
back we want to lead the way on that
make sure that our kids are getting an
education not indoctrination and this
has been ground zero for the left so
that's this is the most important battle
in the culture War Kids you know because
they say the left doesn't have kids they
have yours and so there's a lot to talk
about there so we'll get into it so
thank you absolutely we also have the
one and only
Prime Time 99 Alex Stein on the grind
all the time I'm a pimp on a blip and
Tim I didn't know all of a sudden now
you're a YouTube truther we know that
that yeah you're a YouTube truther he's
sure he's trying to start some
conspiracy this is a non-conspiracy
episode no conspiracies allowed YouTube
sends the notifications to every single
person that has clicked the Bell Tim you
know that I know that all right YouTube
is way better than Tick Tock if you want
to be able to change a 1987 Nissan uh
ultima's alternator you can do that on
YouTube that's a good point try doing
that on Tick Tock well if you want to
learn how to dance to a minute excerpt
of a song that's been sped up
yeah I know but uh you know dancing's
kind of gay so it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
all right good start
Luke prime time 99.
we are change 100. welcome back
beautiful to me because everybody who
made me I can't I can't let Alex come on
here now yell me come on now I come here
with one very simple and and very
rational message
come on not that low not that a little
bit higher pump it up I come I come here
with one just simple rational message
make America Florida if you agree you
could get the shirt that I'm wearing
right now on thebestpoliticalshirts.com
because you do I'm here thank you so
much for having me uh Linda thank you
for also being here and tolerating all
of us and and all the screaming no
problem pray for me tonight guys we'll
be turning down volumes left and right I
had to take my headphones off because
they were deafening me but it's gonna be
an awesome show and I'm really looking
forward to it let's get into it
everybody's yelling Alex
I get so excited Tim I'm sorry I'm a bad
dog
I'll kind of calm down just trying to
talk about the news and this Alex guy
shows up
I wasn't invited if you're watching this
no I just knocked on the door and Tim
didn't want to call the cops for uh
personal reasons
he didn't want me to yell at him with a
camera in his face he's like all right
I'll just let you come on the show no he
just came in the room and I was like
what do we do
he's on the chair now and like Ian he
like Ian was like I'm not going in there
if he's in there and Ian's not here now
I know
no damn Crenshaw Dan Crenshaw gets
scared to death when he sees Primetime
99 with a selfie stick you know he just
puckers up just you know like salt on
his oyster or something let's talk about
the news uh we got this is a crazy story
from timcast.com Facebook worked with
the FBI to spy on conservatives who
questioned the 2020 election the company
has been sending direct messages of its
users to the FBI for 19 months oh that's
crazy and of course all of you know
timcast.com is newsguard certified that
means this reporting is true and correct
you see we do not repeatedly publish
false content good for us we clarify
errors we discover we do disclose
ownership so when people ask you how do
you you know the FBI is not spying with
with Facebook's help you can be a like
News Guard certified website said it was
true here you go a new report from the
New York Post cites sources from within
the U.S Department of Justice who say
someone at Facebook has read flagged
what are deemed to be subversive private
messages over the past 19 months and
transmitted them to the domestic
terrorism unit at FBI headquarters in DC
the post spoke with multiple individuals
who did not wish to be identified quote
it was done outside the legal process
and without probable cause an anonymous
source said Facebook provides the FBI
with private conversations which are
protected by the First Amendment without
any subpoena according to the report the
private messages are then sent to FBI
field offices around the country as
leads which has resulted in the targeted
Facebook users being investigated
Sometimes using covert surveillance
techniques all of the accounts flagged
for domestic Terror is a more
conservative right-wing individuals
it must be just a mistake you know they
forgot to go after antifa yeah a source
said they were gun toting red-blooded
Americans who were angry after the
election and shooting off their mouths
and talking about staging protests there
was nothing criminal nothing about
violence or massacring or assassinating
anyone as soon as a subpoena as soon as
subpoena was requested within an hour
Facebook sent back gigabytes of data and
photos it was ready to go they were just
waiting for that legal process so they
could send it and I also think too they
say they do mention even before that
without any subpoena so a lot of these
were just Facebook being like here you
go buddy have fun
One Source characterized the operation
as a waste of our time now that's
amazing when confronted over the
allegations Facebook first issued a
denial however an hour later Erica's
second spokesperson at Facebook's parent
company meta so the company was working
with the FBI to protect people from harm
and there it is
these claims are false because they
reflect a misunderstanding on how our
systems protect people from harm and how
we engage with law enforcement we
carefully scrutinize all government
requests blah blah blah these claims are
just wrong the suggestion we seek out
people's private messages for
anti-government language or questions
about the validity of past elections and
then proactively Supply those to the FBI
is plainly inaccurate and there is zero
evidence to support it as of September
14th the FBI would neither confirm or
deny the specific allegation of private
messages being shared by Facebook but
said that the agency maintains
relationships with social media
companies the FBI also said it maintains
an ongoing dialogue with social media
platforms to enable a quick exchange of
threat information
so signal do you guys use signal what do
you use
you don't want to tell people what you
use uh first of all because there's a
lot of different platforms up there some
of them are even honey pots I don't
think there's anything sacred there's
there's no privacy online whenever you
have an iPhone or an Android or you're
on Facebook everything you say is going
directly to them and the feds and I just
wanted to comment here there sure seems
to be a lot of connections to Intel
agencies and Facebook especially since
the beginning of that company and even
yesterday Our Guest Devin Nunes I asked
him who's more powerful big Tech social
media or the intelligence agencies he
said that they're the same thing and
they are but but the funny thing was
that he was like that's a good question
yes and he thought about it and then he
talked about something else and I'm like
wait hold on and then and then I had to
ask him again and he was like they're
the same thing and they are they
absolutely are and I want to make this
point and we talk about this in the
conspiracy world and Timmy said a funny
thing about how I'm kind of like Luke's
progeny and I am because Luke has been
well that was before the show so nobody
knows the comments I know but Luke is
you know an OG truther but we'll get
into that but I just want to make this
point too is we have what is known as
Declassified information called
operation Mockingbird and this is in the
70s and this is when the CIA said that
they have represented representatives in
every form of our media radio television
movies and film that was the church
committee hearings yeah specifically
operation Mockingbird was it was a
different operation just a heads up
there's like a little misnosis okay well
listen he's an expert he's a nerd I'm
prime time
my point being is that we know that they
have representatives in all of these
platforms so if you don't think that
social media is not infected with
representatives from the FBI and CIA
you're dreaming and that is why Tick
Tock is so dangerous because Tick Tock
has representatives from the Chinese
government and now they have all of our
information of little kids and Lord
knows these kids are very vulnerable on
there so who knows what what information
they have on and what pictures so that's
all of these social media platforms that
we use that are fully addicting are
basically all DARPA engineered social
media addiction tools to get inside
information about ourselves Twitter uh
whistleblower recently revealed that
there were I think foreign spies in
Twitter and that I think what they said
was well if we've got one then who cares
if there are more let's recruit more
people and wasn't the Saudi government
caught spying on activists that were
protesting them and getting data and
information about that I have to fact
check the story the Saudi Prince buy a
portion of it exactly we cannot talk
about Saudi Arabia without mentioning
the 19 hijackers that uh uh
We're not gonna do that no I'm just
kidding because Luke's on the show sorry
no but we love soccer we're gonna go off
the rails thank you so much we got this
model I like that Alex is here
we love you Saudi right now I can only
imagine the members only segment tonight
will be watch the members only we're
gonna go insane for the Ukraine
Library it's good how you doing Ryan
I'm sorry I wasn't sure what what Alex
how hard he was gonna come in but he's
coming very hard I mean right I mean
man busting out of the wall over there
but yeah I mean you know it is it is
fascinating though you know we you hear
slippery slope it's really not a slope
it's a cliff I mean we you look at
Facebook and social media we talk about
censorship
but this is this is well beyond that and
what we're going to see now is basically
this database this information that is
going to be used against anybody who is
remotely conservative and you know I'm
obviously working with kids thinking
about the future thinking about
education
anything you've ever said anything
you've ever done will be taken
misconstrued and waiting for the day
that you decide to speak up speak out
you're targeted you have an
investigation into you and you know I
mean at this point they are building
basically and off of Oppo file and
anybody who ever remotely is going to do
anything outside the uh the status quo
there when you have we got to stop the
Cults man the the it's it's it's
remarkable people fearing fearing the
cult is why cancel culture works if
there was an opportunity for people to
live and work outside of whatever those
institutions are then no one would care
they'd be like oh you said this five
years ago they'd be like okay great
what's that gonna mean that's right
because in the real world that that does
not impact you until you allow like you
said basically those forces to say you
know what actually a lot of people blew
us up on Facebook today so actually we
are going to fire you or actually we are
going to do this now but if you actually
just go around and just actually
communicate with folks and you actually
talk to real people like you guys were
talking about earlier when we're up
there but but are these actually even
real users I mean are these even real
people that are that are stirring up a
lot of this and you don't even know but
that's what ends up happening it's it's
beyond just the cult because if you look
at big Tech social media they control
the commons they control the information
highways they control what could what
people think Facebook was manipulating
people's emotions Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg literally spent 419 million
dollars ahead of the 2020 elections in
order to fortify it specifically in
major Democratic areas to make sure that
people came out and voted against Donald
Trump Mark Zuckerberg participated
worked with the FBI to censor the hunter
Biden laptop story a story that
according to many political experts
swayed the elections in favor of Joe
Biden clearly Joe Biden is the president
of the intelligence agency he has been
doing their biddings the the social
media companies are not there to be
social media companies they're there to
be the long arm of the big text of of
the intelligence agencies let's also
remember uh Facebook was experimenting
on people yeah we've mentioned it
several times the past week that they
this they they were experimenting people
putting depressing information in their
feed to see how they respond and sure
enough people started getting depressed
they would post depressing things the
same thing was too with positive stuff
we know about that what else do you
think they've done you don't do like I
got to tell you I'm I'm I when they
censor information
it's Overton in our face we see it
happening but I have to imagine this
there's a lot of censorship you don't
see at all we know about Shadow Banning
like we talked about it in the beginning
of the show that people are saying the
link to the to Tim Castile isn't working
that the notifications aren't going out
and then I'm like well who knows what's
happening then I go to our own website
and our own Auto embed feature stopped
working around the exact same time that
so that that's got to be something
there's censorship you can't see but
when it comes to the news feed on
Facebook that's where it gets real dark
because that's totally algorithmic
they're choosing what you do see it's
like not just censorship it's curation
as well so they can make you believe
whatever they want by inundating you and
they're so and gaslighting you and
gaslighting I think one of the things
that's happening is people like us and
the people listen to this show will seek
out something here's the example if
YouTube is not sending out the
notification for this show and people
have pointed that out that means the
people listening chose to come here they
searched for it and they tried to find
it these are people who are
substantially more likely to seek out
information on news events
no it's no wonder these people you know
agree with us on a lot of issues then
you look at the people who aren't
willing to do that they sit in front of
their Facebook they see a headline and
they go and then they keep scrolling and
they believe it and that's what
entrenches the cult
I just want to make this point I think I
said this last time on the show Andrew
Breitbart said that in the future we're
gonna have to have internet ghettos and
that's basically where we're at now is
where you have to have these like little
uh you know your own paywall or your own
platform and that's why I like but it
never works true social is Never Gonna
never gonna be as good as Twitter so
it's it's kind of future I would I would
say yes to a point on that with true
social but the engagement on true social
is actually fairly yeah it's not a
nothing Burger but it's just not the
same it's never going to be the same
there's a reason why you like the ease
of YouTube because the chat is just
efficient or you just you know just
whatever's familiar to you I think I
think that the main issue is only the
most Ardent diehards for the most part
go to platforms like truth or Rumble
yeah we use Rumble infrastructure and we
do post to rumble but when you're trying
to reach independent voters and normies
you know you've got to be on the
platforms wherever you got to fish where
the fish are as the same goes
yeah and I mean and what you've seen is
they had control of Legacy Media
then I was talking to you guys about
this you know it's funny because my
background in education you know they
all you know the conventional wisdom is
kids you know they can't pay attention
for more than 20 minutes of a Time
learning needs to look like this and
what do you know the most digested form
of media amongst young people are
podcasts like yours this long form let's
do deep Dives they they love it they
love the challenging of of you know
conventional wisdom let's talk through
this let's do a deep dive let's
investigate this stuff they will go
along with that but now guess what the
left says well we control Legacy Media
well we've got to make sure that these
folks aren't able to get to more people
so now we've got a I mean it's a
constant game of control obviously but
it also shows that now they know Legacy
Media is dying newspaper industry is
dying so now we've got to control the
podcast because again I I mean I I come
back to this Ground Zero is our is the
war on our young people because the
reality is if they can control them and
to your point Tim if they control the
entire narrative and that's what most of
them see the only people that are gonna
be able to find the information the true
the truth Seekers and the people willing
to go above and beyond to do that
let me uh let me jump to one of the
stupidest stories but it relates to this
to it to a great degree
from the wrap CNN's Lisa France calls
out Matt Walsh's weird scientific
objection to a black Little Mermaid they
have they have laundered this story
several times now here's the story Matt
Walsh says on his show I don't care if
if anyone of any race is playing any
character it's basically how it was in
the 90s and and that's totally fine I
just don't like the double standard and
for that matter he's like can we talk
about the science of a mermaid like
underwater it wouldn't make sense to
have dark skin because the sea creatures
down there have no pigmentation So Not
only would she be very pale she'd be
translucent translucent like some kind
of horrifying floating skeleton it was a
joke it was nonsense obviously The
Little Mermaid isn't a floating skeleton
the next thing that happens is they say
Matt Walsh makes racist Claim about
Little Mermaid they omit stuff then you
get David French being like here's Matt
Walsh's argument for why Ariel should be
white which he never said now the story
has become his weird scientific
objection to a black little mermaid when
his whole when his his whole point was
he's okay with actors of any race
playing any character they have
laundered the story to that degree this
is the media Now CNN Lisa France calls
out Mash so what's going to happen now
they've laundered the story it's
completely fabricated and someone's
gonna be watching CNN drooling staring
at the screen confused and they're going
to say Matt Walsh said racist things and
they're gonna go whoa well that's how
you entrench the code that doesn't make
sense though because the idea of a
little mermaid is racist because a woman
doesn't just have to be a maid she can
be uh the CEO she can be the president
she doesn't have to be a maid so I don't
like Disney doing that little these
little girls are smart a lot of them
just because they're good at cleaning
and cooking doesn't mean that she has to
be a maid hold on there a minute I just
kind of thought of something so uh it's
actually from the word Maiden
does that mean the word made literally
just means young woman so when you're
like I gotta call a maid you're
literally saying I need a young woman
yeah yeah that's what it is yeah that's
kind of funny that liking it all the
time young woman is synonymous with
person who cleans your house yeah isn't
that crazy so here's what happens right
uh the Newsweek runs this story Matt
Walsh slammed for saying black Little
Mermaid isn't scientific okay Matt
Walsh's actual segment and quote was
hilarious he said if anything not only
should The Little Mermaid be pale she
should actually be translucent and
adding that if you look at deep sea
creatures they're like translucent they
have no kind of pigmentation whatsoever
and they're just like these horrifying
skeletons floating around in the ocean
he's not wrong that's what the Little
Mermaid should look like she should be
totally pale and skeletal where you can
see her skull through her face and that
would actually be a little version of
Little Mermaid I would watch me too so
this is
Cassandra McDonald formerly Cassandra
Fairbanks posted it's like an angler
fish looking aerial with like purple
hair this is one I really like though
The Little Mermaid and it's this
horrifying looking skeletal monster I
love how he made a joke about The Little
Mermaid having her skull be visible
through her face and then the entirety
of the meat is just like we got him and
they run this crazy story about him
being racist when you I love these
stories because when we can drive to the
root of how they lied it gives you an
understanding as to how the media in
every facet is lying to you about what's
going on in the world
um Matt Walsh also called himself a
translucent rights activist which is
important to bring up here but I think
this whole thing is a distraction I
think this from the very beginning I
think this is just something to waste
our time and I think Disney loves this I
think this is the way that now the major
movie industry knows that they could
sell the movie by creating controversy
what better way to create a controversy
than to create this artificial character
that of course they know people are
going to debate they know people are
going to have a conversations about they
know is going to spur on debate people
call this uh fan baiting and I think
this is all marketing this is all PR by
Disney trying to of course promote their
movie at the end of the day this is what
it is I love
I love love I love these months it's
Ariel with like an angler fish light and
like big teeth and big bulbous eyes uh
one thing we're we're not talking about
the elephant in the room that all Disney
movies are based on trauma-based mind
control with the main character losing a
very close-loved person at the very
beginning like their parent or their
discipline oh yeah everyone let's go to
a Little Mermaid her mom yeah her mom
died yep Little Mermaid's mom dies yeah
how did she die she gets caught in like
a trawler's net a fishing net yeah she
gets eat Jason Momo she gets put in just
a Momoa domestic violence terrible it's
all trauma-based mind control it is it
is but it really is the Disney stuff is
because it's supposed to you know also
that's how they get the little kids
hooked by the trauma it creates like
this cortisol response a little kid's
like what I'm so sad but then it you
know has this like fake you know uh
fairy tale what happened to Ariel's mom
I'm not sure I don't think they ever say
do they I think we should make a short
where she gets caught in like a trawler
she's like then she goes right into the
grinder
but while this story is both I love the
humerus output you know with the
ridiculous looking Ariel but no this is
an important point because when you're
reading a story about say Donald Trump
this is how you understand you can you
can drive from this story to its root
and because it's a little mermaid it's
something that regular people might
actually understand if you go to them
and you say hey did you know the the
Shinzo Abe hoax and they'll go The Who
The Shins Japan and Trump and the fish I
don't know what you're talking about you
go to and say you know the new Little
Mermaid movie yeah you hear about that
racist guy yeah look at this yep
something they've already been primed to
like they've heard right it's like when
um that dude from flakka's talks goes in
the street and says who's George
Washington like I don't know name the
Kardashian sisters and they're like oh
it's so Chloe
so I I like this you know and also I'm
having a good time it's funny Matt's
funny guy I I love lgbtq Nation wrote
that he was having a meltdown and then
like anybody who knows Matt Walsh is
like a Matt Walsh the most extreme
version of his meltdown is him going to
be going like huh okay yeah yeah
I think you're right I think that it's
always great to show people the extremes
a left go to set in a narrative and how
much the media just actively will push
something that's just the complete
opposite of what the case may be and
when it's funny it plays more also and
that's where you get this where this
will stick in people's heads of another
outrageous attempt to to make Matt Walsh
into something that he's not so I mean
hey it kind of checks all the boxes to
illustrate that it's amazing that
they're like he said a mermaid shouldn't
be black and they stop because if they
did the full context he said the mermaid
should have translucent skin with her
skull being exposed you'd be like I
don't understand how that's racist what
is that so that's why he made himself a
pro-translucent activist and everyone's
saying he's pro-trans so yeah but guys
in 20 years Little Mermaid will be
transgender
20. do you think it'd be less that's too
long well when did when did the it was
1989 when the little mermaid cartoon
came out so it's actually been you know
it's been like 30 33 years well yeah
you're right we're in the acceleration
uh phase of this where yeah it'll
probably be two years and and I I know
Ryan here is to talk about education but
Ryan what do you think that we went
wrong we're in schools now they have
these you know transition closets or
these t-shirts you see Libs of tick tock
like why do you think they're so
motivated to indoctrinate kids it's
almost like they're coordinated or
almost 100 as coordinated you know I
mean and that's where you look at this
and and I'll give you an example of what
happened in Oklahoma we had a teacher
who was giving kids access to
pornography in the classroom that didn't
make sense like what what so hey so I go
out and go okay she said she broke full
off she said that she's going to keep
breaking the law then she's shown
pornography to kids we need to take her
teaching certificate that's literally
what the law said yeah okay right
well then the media starts in this
narrative that I'm after all the
teachers I'm like not after all the
teachers I'm after one teacher's
teaching certificate because she was
giving access to pornography and they go
well that's censorship I go no
no what is appropriate for kids in
school is not censorship right and then
real quick yeah was she a government
employee yes it's not it's not you can
call it censorship sure but it's not a
violation of one a or First Amendment
rights when the government tells the
government it can't do something that's
exactly right but again so then well
I'll take it a step further then the
media in Oklahoma run this list of quote
banned books in Oklahoma yeah it came
from an international group that said
hey we've looked at Oklahoma's law so we
think these books are banned there and
they run it for a week and I'm going out
there every every day going we don't
have any banned books we just have a
mine you cannot give pornography to a
minor law that's like been around like
every state for 30 years I mean but but
the media has run with this narrative
and tried to paint it as well hey if
you're going to question her you're
going after all teachers that's not true
and number two you're trying to ban but
I mean they're going hey he's going to
ban Huckleberry Finn and why do they
always ban Huck fans that has the n-word
I guess yeah that's why there is but I
mean just that book is required reading
NSC 1984 and in Brave New World they're
getting banned why because of predictive
programming why I mean why I mean why do
you think those are getting better well
and again I don't you know they set this
up they're not fiction anymore
what's the cat out of the bag I guess
but you know it's not Republicans it's
not conservatives it's not Libertarians
pushing Banning of books there's a
difference between having conversations
about I mean again and I had someone I
had a reporter say hey but you know kids
can get porn on their phone I go hold on
so the argument is yeah it's out there
so we should have it in the school
library for second graders yeah that's
outrageous under your point it's part
the left is intentionally trying to
indoctrinate kids push them away from
their parents because guess what you go
home and tell your parents about it they
go wait what's going on so the kid
further withdraws from their parents
they want there to be no hey male female
they're those don't matter there's
really no gender or there's no sex it's
fluid and it becomes this confusing
we're gonna have the most confused
generation in the history of the United
States there was a story about a woman I
was reading I think it was a social
media post and she said that her
daughter was in school and the school
had been transitioning her daughter
without her knowing her daughter was
growing increasingly depressed and what
it happened what it seems like from the
story I mean maybe it's not true it's an
anecdote is that the girl was becoming
depressed because the school was telling
her and encouraging her and pushing her
and everyone around her is goading her
and saying yes yes and then she
eventually told her mom she don't want
to go to school anymore because it was
giving her anxiety and then as soon as
she stopped going to school she she
stopped all the pronoun stuff she
stopped the transition stuff because
apparently the story is she never wanted
to but she was being pressured to that's
kind of creepy and scary yeah I mean
it's become you know you have activists
that are pushing it and I mean again
these are kids I mean this is probably
you know my background is as a teacher
you have to take responsibility very
seriously as a teacher to go these are
young impressionable kids
I'm not going to sit here and push an
ideology or push a point of view on them
I want them to have multiple points of
view and come to their own conclusion
but now you've got the left who's
decided we're going to dress Folks up
and pretend to be teachers then they're
going to go in there and they're going
to push this and then you create this
culture of it to your point young people
are going to be so confused it causes
depression it causes frustrations and it
doesn't equal a job it doesn't equal
them getting an education that is
Meaningful it's not going to grab the
story real quick from the postmodial
Arizona superintendent sued over a sex
chat room for minors the lawsuit alleges
Hoffman advertised links to chat rooms
where miners discuss sex and gender with
adults present and without parents
necessarily knowing this according to AZ
free news the lawsuit filed in the
Maricopa County superior court alleges
Hoffman advertise links so we read that
judge Peter Thompson Will preside the
chat rooms have have Quick Escape
functions that Hoffman claims violate
Arizona's parents Bill of Rights in the
suit it specifies how hoppin advertised
Q chat space which is aimed at lgbtq
youth 13 years and older
chat rooms include sex and relationships
q a for Trans non-binary youth activism
and allyship four trans non-binary youth
sex ed
yeah so these schools are having these
conversations with your kids and they're
encouraging them to speak this is the
crazy thing it's not the first time
we've heard this where they bring minors
into rooms with adults without the
parents knowing knowing like come on man
because it's amazing to me it wasn't
that long ago that I mean like hey you
know I would I would see a student at
Walmart and it was weird for them you
know I mean it's like you have kids and
a wife and I'm like yeah but you know I
mean you're in the classroom you're
teaching academics you're going through
the stand I mean and to them it's like a
Bizarro world to see you like in real
life you know we've gone from that to
hey we're going to bring in minors we're
going to talk about sex and we're going
to talk about your sexual orientation
we're going to talk about your your
gender it's outrageous it's amazing how
quickly we've gone from that type of
perspective to just full-on
indoctrination and it's not just schools
it's parades it's public showings it's
TV shows it's movie series it's social
media where of course it's promoted in
the algorithm and the people and young
kids especially are gaslit that this is
okay and they get special brownie points
on the internet they get more likes they
get more are playing the algorithm if
they declare that they're a part of the
larger accepted group that of course
everyone wants them to be which is
absolutely crazy I just learned about
the the transition rooms that you were
telling me I just looked it up that also
is kind of mind-boggling to see these
type of things going on at school
without the participation of the parents
and this is why I think homeschooling
has been on such a huge rise and I think
if there's a caveat to any of this it's
that people are finally learning because
of covid because the last two years
because of all the zoom calls they're
finally seeing all the horrendous things
that their kids are being indoctrinated
to that they're saying enough is enough
we're taking the kids from school we're
teaching them the important things that
they actually will use in life and and
changing the game this way there's
millions of people homeschooling and I
think this is a a sign that you think is
is a positive and a good I got to make
this point though as an app developer
myself you know having the Quick Escape
function is when you have a really good
honest app you always have to have
something so you can Tetris quickly exit
out of it so you don't get caught
speaking to a child I mean just the fact
that they're speaking I mean seriously
they're like oh we got to have a
function Quick Escape functionality in
case somebody walks in the room I mean
that's sick that's perverted and that's
it goes to and the reason why I thought
about that is when you talk about the
transition Clauses it's like you know
you have to talk about this with a
developer like oh we we may need to be
able to get out of this instantly
because we could be talking about
something that's very demonic or evil so
it just that just shows you how much how
many layers are inappropriate and how
illegal yeah of course yeah so you know
that that website should not exist and
that's a teacher doing it so well so
what what's uh what's going on with the
uh with you and say school choice or
homeschooling or micro schooling right
you know I I couldn't agree more that
what we've seen is a parent sort of
opened their eyes through covid seeing
what's going on in the classrooms to say
we want more school choice we want more
options for our kids hey if a parent
wants to homeschool kid or send them to
a private school and these micro schools
I'm glad you brought that up we are
seeing incredible Innovation that's
going on because hey a parent a couple
of teachers go hey we we can we can do
project-based learning we can have kids
develop their own company I mean we can
we can have you do create a startup here
you go here here's some materials you
guys started up and we'll we'll help
work through all that we can do math
science through this type of innovation
and it's really unlocking the potential
and again
this whole one size fits-all model in
education has to stop we all know that
like you know not everybody takes the
traditional path to be successful in
life and we push kids in it and when we
make them feel like failures when they
don't go down that road this is why I
thought school was just miserable
because like for me
that we would spend one whole week on a
sub subject that I would learn in 10
minutes they'd open the book and be like
here's this you know current lesson
today and at the end of the week you
take a test so like on day one I read it
I'm like I get it yeah I'm good and then
I'm sitting there and they punish me for
it they say you're being bad you're not
paying attention you're in trouble you
get attention public school's a scam I
mean it's it's an indoctrination Center
that was literally created on the
foundations of the Rockefeller family
that wanted good slave workers that were
going to be good obedient workers in the
factory everything is based on that old
principle Society doesn't run this way
anymore we don't have any factories the
Rockefellers along with Henry Kissinger
and and Nixon sent them over to China
when they opened up China to the rest of
the world but but but this is again a
failed system that is failing our
country our IQs have been going down
dramatically intelligence and and
emotional health has been going down
dramatically and I think this is done
deliberately and I think this is a
success of the system rather than a
failure because when you truly look at
how the system and why the system was
started it's starts to make a lot more
sense that's exactly right I mean that's
where understanding that it was
developed in the industrial revolution
to say we want to have good Factory
workers and what did we want we wanted
first of all to make sure they could go
tend the crops which is why we had
Summers off so that they could tend
Harvest that's literally the reason for
the schedule and we still have the I
mean lunch breaks specifically so
regurgitate repeat follow orders follow
the procedures punch the hole exactly
where we tell you to punch the hole in
and
was designed in order to do and now we
live in this incredibly agile economy
where literally the thing that is most
productive is the ability to be uh you
know be creative uh be Innovative you
know be able to create on your own and
think outside the box and think about
things differently and literally have a
system in place that does not help that
flourish doesn't build upon that as a
premise and so that's what we've got to
continue to do is to push for an
education system that unlocks the
potential of every learner and that
means it's different that means it's
different for every learner and to your
point
if you have a learner that can take off
let them take off why are we slowing
them down and why are we allowing
ourselves to overly regulate and push a
model on kids that frankly like I said
you can talk to people every day they
don't follow the traditional path to be
successful hey College guess what a lot
of people don't want to send their kids
to college that's not even the
traditional way to be successful never
has been it's a myth moderate uh
relative I think that only emerged with
the millennial generation for the most
part gen xers probably to a certain
degree more so and mostly Millennials I
don't I I think maybe look at the data
because for me it's just what I what I
understand about the narratives they
give us all the time is that you know
the greatest Generation had high school
diplomas and fed their families and the
Boomers didn't go to college some of
them did many of them did but most or a
large amount didn't and they were still
able to work jobs and be successful such
a you know sixty percent of okolonians
don't go to college
and we look at the jobs you know Walmart
right now is running this on a loop
they've got their commercial of they are
starting semi truck drivers at six
figures wow you can go here for for six
weeks you get a CDO license you can get
behind a truck and you start 120 000
dollars
there are kids I get to travel around
the country I get this kind of training
I get I get anabolic benefits are great
too but you start looking through this
and go College this whole all kids
should go to college it's been a myth
and to your point it's never actually
been true the majority of people never
have gone to college so again doctors
lawyers sure go to college but the
reality is we have pushed kids down a
path for so long and said this was what
success looks like and by the way if you
don't do that you're not a success and
then you wonder why kids a lot of kids
hate school then you wonder why by the
way teachers get frustrated in that
environment there's a meme where it's a
woman looking at her kid and as a
garbage man and she's like it's a
political cartoon she's like you better
go to college otherwise you're going to
end up like him and then the guy's like
I make six figures and have health care
benefits like like you're ragging on the
garbage guy garbage man and he's getting
paid way better than all these college
grads it's it's crazy to think and and
also it's just another problem with that
it's a liberal Elite mentality and a lot
of neocon conservative types have this
too the Suburban families that like
there's demeaning work that like you
don't want to do that job that's a bad
job why would you like it's like these
are very important jobs that people got
to do and it's like you should be
eternally grateful someone's willing to
handle your bag of crap and take it out
of your house could you imagine these
people would be crying in two seconds if
the if the if the sanitation workers
were just like you know what take your
own trash now you can be that person and
they're gonna be like please please
there's feces yeah they'll beg they'll
beg and cry it's so elitist and
condescending too because you know we
looked at this you know I know I
remember which think tanka was but they
did kind of a study on happiness you
know what who who says their most
fulfilled by their job I don't know if
you if you guys remember saying I think
it was AI but it was a one of the
highest rated ones was a custodian at a
school
and the reason why was because the
custodian felt and saw kids that were
excited to go play on the playground
they were excited to be at school and he
realized and again that group realized
what I'm doing every day is helping make
kids happy and these teachers are
thankful they come to me and tell me
thanks and again that's a job that you
would think hey you know cleaning up a
school every day they rated it as one of
the most yeah one of the happiest uh you
know occupations because they said look
we see what we're doing as a fulfillment
to society and that's a reality though
but the liberal Elites think that a PhD
and you know underwater basket weaving
or some are you know humanity is the
end-all be-all even if you don't have a
job even if there's not a job on it they
think that means success rather than
contributing to society who was it on
The View who thought that uh Joe's that
Jill Biden was a doctor Sonny hoston I
think was it I think she was alive Jill
is a good doctor she's a good doctor and
they're like she's actually not a doctor
she's not she has an education doctorate
or whatever close enough I would let her
do surgery on me but hey I want to make
a point I couldn't get in I couldn't get
in on the education thing and I want to
say you know I thought the Rockefellers
did a good job uh you know creating a
curriculum of uh good workers and I
think it did a good job but for me when
Barack Obama's husband got rid of the
square pizza Michelle that is when I
lost all my love for uh public schooling
because once once they took away the
good food oh I remember those pizzas I
actually like and Michelle Obama got rid
of him trying to make everybody go vegan
Michelle let us eat some cheese pizza I
know you guys love cheese pizza
yeah we used to we used to have those
you know those squares and it was like
the cheese who knows what it was we had
blue hot dogs that was the weirdness
wait why were they blue was that
Gatorade I wouldn't need them they were
gray so they were they were like if
you'd walk in and there was like hot
dogs and like I think they were boiling
them and then they'd like they put them
like the craziest thing about school
food is it never made sense they'd give
you a hot dog with no bun because it was
just like whatever they had but it we
would very often hot dogs would be gray
and then sometimes they would be blue
bluish gray and I just I wouldn't still
healthier than a vegan diet but that's a
second point to make here
anyway let's let's let's do a hard
Segway we're gonna jump to the uh the
big story
Daily Mail says Martha's Vineyard
declares a humanitarian crisis over
influx of just 50 Venezuelan migrants
Republicans slam liberal Islands
pathetic reaction and ask what are the
thousands arriving in Texas every single
day I love this did you guys see Kareem
jean-pierre's response where she's like
it's it's a it's a cruel and unusual
thing to send people to Martha's
Vineyard not like calm down man stop
bragging on Martha's Vineyard dude it's
actually like Ron DeSantis I'm kind of
jealous like why does he get to give
them a flight to Martha's video what
about me yeah you know no for real like
I I gotta be honest
he could have just randomly chosen 50
Floridians and been like you're getting
a vacation in Martha's Vineyard instead
the illegal immigrants are the ones who
get this luxurious vacation yeah well
look at the immigrants that go to New
York they get a hotel in uh in Times
Square so I mean yeah that's what I
believe that they did originally it was
like 600 a night and then they stopped
that policy that was the policy in the
first few uh first few weeks but but
it's not a vacation they're kicking them
out if you see the the government
officials from Martha's Vineyard they're
coming out they're like these people
can't stay here
there's 50 of them they're calling for
federal assistance right now they're
calling in emergency meetings 50 people
how many mansions do they have over
there how many rooms does Barack Obama
beach front mansion that by the way
somehow can't be affected by the rising
Tides he keeps warning everyone about
how in the world he has so many rooms
let him in let him in the Mansions why
why aren't they why why are they being
so selfish why are you being so so
disgustingly rude Christina peshaw
tweeted wow this Martha Venus Democrat
doesn't seem very welcoming or
Progressive quote we don't have housing
for 50 immigrants uh don't the Obamas
have a 10 bedroom mansion there minimum
half of them yeah
yeah so the Obamas have eight rooms in
their house they have seven and a half
bathrooms they have 30 Acres on a little
piece of Martha's Vineyards that's set
to be at Martha's Vineyard that's said
to be underwater in like five years
according to them it's not me saying
this and I can't you know this lady
who's talking about housing these people
Martha's Vineyard is really small
they're very small population it's
likely that they don't have housing for
50 people right now but at the same time
you know exactly what you voted for I
think this is brilliant there's tons of
properties on Martha's Vineyard Vineyard
that are vacant yeah
but there's houses and they're not all
big mansions some are like one bedroom
one bathroom little like little Cottages
so I get it those are privately uh you
know privately owned but hey how about
this how about all the rich people you
know you own a 15 million dollar mansion
why don't you you guys pull your
resources together send it to the
government so the government can do what
you want them to do because you guys
like helping migrants right so why don't
you pull your money the government can
then buy some of these houses and start
housing these migrants what's wrong well
see the troll in me loves that they're
sending them there but the pragmatic
Primetime 99 Alex sign which is I'm
usually not like that I don't want to
send these immigrants all the way deep
into America let's send them back to
their home on a first class ticket well
so I said this too and people pointed
out that the states don't have the
international like the authority to
deport people I'm sure so it's like
international relations are negotiated
at the federal level so the state of
Texas can't just
send people they I think they could but
I think there's like an international
incident we literally have an invasion
on our border it's not just people from
South America it's people from Russia
people from the Middle East that are
coming through every day and it's just
from Africa yeah but it's a sex
trafficking it's a drug trafficking I
think they did I think they took a woman
in for rape kit and she had semen
samples in her from 22 different people
and I think the semen samples only live
for like 48 hours or something so and
there's things called rape trees out
there I mean it's disgusting where you
know kids will find underwear they'll
find tampons they'll find all kinds of
stuff that insinuated that there was
some sort of sexual trauma that happened
on that scene so it's not okay when
these these parents literally use their
kids as collateral to to send them
coyotes they need to send the national
guard down to the border and just shut
it down they need the regular army there
not just the National Guard instead of
having a base in every other country we
need to put bases on our border and try
to protect our U.S citizens 108 000 drug
overdose deaths this past year we have a
fentanyl crisis that is killing literal
children left and right day after that's
the CIA
probably bringing that one and you talk
about the Iran Contra which we were
trading with Nicaragua guns and then we
were bringing them in and Barry seal was
flying these drugs all of Kane into the
United States making it crack cocaine
and of course selling it to the poor
communities Freeway Ricky Ross
the news would then run stories where
they would be like on the corner of 63rd
and Cicero another Super heroine death
and then the next day they'd be like 16
deaths last night after we ran that
report no joke they would run reports
telling people where it happened and
then the addicts would rush there and be
like I want to buy it and the next day
they'd be like even more dead yeah I
just to go back to this topic 50 those
are rookie numbers Barack Obama during
covet had hundreds of people at his
birthday party at Martha's Vineyards
let's bring them all have have Obama
host them Obama's a big fan favorite of
course bringing people in here Kamala
Harris also had immigrants show up at
her doorstep today in Washington DC uh
as she was doing interviews saying that
yeah of course the Border was very
secure I think I think uh Abbott and uh
the Santa should send more planes to
Martha's Vineyard and it's mostly
because it is a beautiful nice safe
wealthy place the fact that yeah in the
Hamptons the fact that they're saying
like how dare you be so cruel like so
cruel we sent these people to one of the
wealthiest places in the country y'all
can take care of them they're going to
live better than they would have lived
anywhere else absolutely and and they're
at the richest place in the world almost
and and specifically when you send them
to new to New York the mayor is even
saying it's too dangerous for immigrants
to be inside of New York City because of
the rising violence so so why send them
to New York Martha's Vineyard seems fine
for me well and then have you guys seen
the complaint from Mexico City about the
gentrification of all the world isn't
that funny how it works out like that
yeah I would think a bunch of white
people come oh get out of here they're
making stuff rent more expensive and
they're not speaking Spanish they're
speaking English
I got to be honest like when these uh
when these hipster liberal woke types
discover that Mexico City actually
wasn't all sepia toned and it was
actually a fairly cool climate with the
delicious food and amazing people all of
a sudden they were like I'd rather be
there especially yeah especially with
the remote working too that's what they
said everybody I've been there so many
times I love it down there real quick
how come like How come every meaty
depiction of Mexico is sepia it's like
it's like you've never been there well
why is it Texas this guy in a horse a
Mexican or Sombrero I mean it's always
the stereotype you know yeah I also
learned that Mexican food is actually
not Mexican food when you go to a
Mexican restaurant it's a Tex-Mex oh
yeah that makes sense but I think like
most people from Mexico realize that
they come up here and they're like what
is this and you know what's a burrito
and what we've seen here you know Thomas
Seoul talked about this a lot but you
know liberals never have to actually
live with the consequences of their
actions I mean that's the reality the
far left they live all hey this doesn't
open border there's not an open border
well all of a sudden what you've seen
Governor DeSantis do is put it right on
no no actually you can you can you can
deal with a little bit of whatever
Border Town whatever every state is
dealing with near the southern border
and make them deal with the consequence
and boy they don't like it dude I just
I'm imagining DeSantis signing off on
this and they're like he's like I got
two planes let's put 50 and they're like
laughing and they're just like look
this is it's insane to me that they're
calling it cruel to the immigrants I
don't think anyone's buying it I think
you're going to have some working class
family you know making 50k a year trying
to support their kids and they're like
you think being sent to Martha's
Vineyard is cruel Tim we won't let Novak
Djokovic come in and defend his title
literally because he will not get a
vaccine that is the most safe and
effective thing ever I have six vouchers
thank you for creating it I'll miss you
Dr fauci but if you are an illegal
immigrant we'll let you come in we'll
give you a cell phone if you're young
enough we'll give you a social security
number and we'll give you a first class
ticket to Martha's Vineyard to go to
Barack Obama's birthday
what do you think would happen if they
sent like 300 people
but maybe that's the only way to get the
attention of these uppity wealthy
liberal types I mean Obama lives there
maybe the only way to make them finally
do something is to be like we're gonna
put it in your lap yes they have to
suffer the consequences yep of the of
the policies that they are pushing and
they have been allowed to get away with
it for far too long where it's other
Americans that suffer the consequences
and they have built themselves an ivory
Tower far from it and it's time for that
to stop this is something Thomas Soul
talks about he talks about it is
dangerous to put people in charge who
pay no consequences when things go wrong
this is exactly what they're saying this
is why I said this is brilliant I I kind
of agree with Alex hold on let's look at
this no no continue continue I agree
with Alex that I don't feel like we
should be pushing them into the country
but at the same time if you don't hold
politicians accountable they'll just
keep doing what they're doing look at
that just put us in the situation what
is this
they deserve better than being left on
the streets of DC or being left in
Martha's Vineyard they deserve deserve a
lot better than that
that's yeah like I'm on the streets in
Texas yeah or New York City right just
not in our homes just please get them
out of here isn't it amazing I said that
just like DC or Martha's Vineyard she
didn't say Texas she didn't say El Paso
she just in New York City yes it's just
where we are yeah just get him away oh I
despise these these people are just so
scummy and Evil
man they vote for things that won't
because they won't face the consequences
like you were saying they live in big
cities and they vote to take away the
guns from a dude who lives in bare
country they're like you shouldn't be
able to have more than 10 rounds in your
weapon it's like what if I'm attacked by
a bear I don't care screw you or pigs
the meme was 30 to 50 feral Hogs and the
left went nuts laughing that doesn't
happen and then all these people in the
country were like dude feral Hogs are
extremely dangerous and we go on hog
shoots because they destroy your
property and they can kill kids
yeah we can take away your guns because
we've got a dozen armed security guards
that follow us around us you know
encircle us wherever we go but you know
what you guys don't need guns I mean
it's just the hypocrisy yeah well and I
want to make this point too and I think
it was Thomas Jefferson that said this
but this is the problem with democracy
is that it's two wolves and a sheep
deciding what's for dinner so you know
what I mean nothing's ever going to be
fair and if you get the populace on your
side we'd actually don't even have a
populist movement they always say oh you
know the old ultramaget is more of the
populist movement my point being is that
we are not well we're not represented
correctly by the people in power and I
think that's why we're subjugated to so
much strife and that's where we fight
with each other instead of actually
fixing look at this one this one from
timcast.com Governor JB pritzker orders
emergency declaration following arrival
of illegal immigrants from Texas Mayor
Lori Lightfoot and Texas governor Greg
Abbott have been exchanging Barbed
comments in the last month I love how
they sit back and just gloat voting for
these policies as Texas Arizona and
other Southern border states New Mexico
suffer the moment these states say y'all
can share in the Bounty for which you
have sown they go emergency oh how could
you do this you're so evil the claim of
emergencies in Illinois in New York
Martha's Vineyard DC it's pathetic but
you know what
maybe this is the only way the only way
to make a change the only way to get
these people to stop doing it
be in line with how by
mega mega horrible people are they're
like not part of our our democracy uses
their positions in power to punish
conservatives and those against them in
the country I mean that is they take it
and it is it is a game of how do we
leverage this to punish those that are
against us and this is what this is what
you see hey as long as it's in Texas as
long as it's in Oklahoma as long as it's
in these red States great as soon as it
gets in our states it is a state of
emergency yes exactly those consequences
that we've ignored for decades I say
keep it up keep it up keep it up Abbott
DeSantis DeSantis should send more
planes out 100 because the other thing
too is
aside from the politics of it
if you're getting if Florida attacks are
being overwhelmed and they can't
properly care for these people they need
to send them somewhere why so why not
just send them to where these people
voted for it and I they're Sanctuary
cities too you know DC to Sanctuary City
California Sanctuary state right but
here's what I want to point out you know
they're secretly happy about this
when the census comes around I think
we're like what eight years out or
something like that this is going to
give them more congressional seats Tim
they say voter ID is racist you
freaking back
dog at 7-Eleven
I mean that's all you need to know of
course everybody need this Charlie Chris
in uh Florida says that there should be
vax mandates again of course they love
that they love events and that's not
racist having to show an ID and a
vaccine card to eat spaghetti at Olive
Garden that's not racist but having to
show an ID to vote an election that is I
would love it the policy was
specifically about hot dogs at 7-Eleven
it was just like everything else is fine
but
well we don't know what's in them and
they're probably dirty so because we do
have liability here at 7-Eleven so we'd
prefer if you were vaccinated for it no
but but that it just kind of shows you
the hypocrisy of this and I think you're
exactly right that there is some sort of
uh ulterior motive with the Border being
I think I think they're just scumbags I
think they just sit well so did you not
see did you not see the message they
asked one of the immigrants and the
immigrants thought that the borders open
they're under the impression that it is
here's here's an example they say we
gotta go green and you go okay nuclear
power is very very you know uh there's a
lot of energy density in nuclear and
they go oh nuclear is bad and you're
like okay well oh come on like you're
telling me there's no solution and then
we got to stop what we're doing that
makes no sense the policy from these
people that we got to get off fossil
fuels but that we can't use Green
Technology like nuclear then they want
they say oh we'll do we'll do solar and
wind even though we don't have the
batteries for it they're not offering
you Solutions they're offering you
destruction they're offering you
problems yeah but Tim this is just that
is just a perfect example of what we're
going through it's called the Great
reset and I know there's different
iterations of the great reset but once
they take us off the fossil fuels and
we're on a battery then they can control
every micro micro transaction that you
go through whether starting your car
turning on your cell phone so that's why
they want it so depending on the
greatest so we have no Independence
whatsoever Action Man uh Super Chat he
said let's send feral Hogs to Dem
strongholds
what did you see in Pennsylvania or
somewhere where there's a limit to the
clips a guy almost got killed by a hog
yeah because he didn't have no bullets
Italy somewhere yeah or wherever that
was a viral video in Italy where a hog
charges a guy and he's only allowed
three rounds and they don't stop the hug
yeah it almost gets him in Poland
recently there was a child that died
because of hogs you know he attacked him
and killed him it was a big story
everywhere so people get pigs are brutal
like I went to uh I went to a County
Fair recently and they have a whole
bunch of big fat pigs laying around and
people were like oh the pigs will kill
you they'll eat you oh yeah you got to
go in there you gotta like Whack Him to
get them away from you and stuff but you
fall down they'll just be like food
now imagine yes now imagine feral you
know feral Hogs running around
before we move on from the immigration
thing and then I'll be quiet for a
little while do you guys remember that
Joe effing Biden sent 70 7-0 planes to
Tallahassee Florida in the dead of night
full of illegal immigrants and now
they're talking about DeSantis human
trafficking oh Biden was trafficking
kids yes literally into like Tennessee
into Westchester New York Florida and
Florida yeah the Biden Mission and
they're probably still doing it I'm sure
they are so you look you can't trust the
media man you know we're gonna we're
gonna push I was thinking about this
earlier and I was just thinking about
how like the left has become just this
Cult of do whatever you're told and then
I thought it was funny because of that
old you know Pink Floyd thing mother
should I trust the government like it
used to be mainstream acceptable to be
like you shouldn't and so then I was
like I have an idea we're making a shirt
and it's uh I probably shouldn't say but
I'm gonna say it anyway because I
because I think it's funny and it says
mother it's a little girl asking her mom
mother should I trust the government and
they're outside at 7-Eleven and she says
yes and the 7-Eleven guy's injecting her
in the arm with the vaccine
I'm like that that pretty much sums up
where we're at in my opinion yeah I love
the vaccine oh speaking of orphanages we
didn't mention Laura Silsby getting
called 20 Haitian uh orphans at the
border and uh Hillary Clinton bailing oh
yeah what are you talking about that
what's her name Laura Silsby that was a
big thing
no that's fake news you guys that's
debunked that's uh that's totally
totally debunked uh NPR says Laura
Stills be Haitian orphans would be
rescuer serial rule breaker she's a
rescuer see yeah
good for her yeah what is it where did
it say she was arrested Lauren Silsby I
think she was arrested at the Haitian
border and I think Hillary Clinton they
raised like 280 million dollars for
Haiti and I think they built like 11
houses or something like that barely
that yeah the whole Clinton Global
initiative was a money laundering scam
operation that of course was just the
government including Ukraine Ukraine
donated a bunch of money to the Clinton
Global initiative it's just a big
mistake uh Idaho Press News Guard
certified says Laura Silsby convicted in
Haiti but free to go it must be just one
big misunderstood and didn't Hillary
Clinton give the Mining rights to one of
their relatives to mine in Haiti in
exchange for all the benefits that they
got there I interviewed a Haitian that
gave me a very passionate speech about
the destruction that the clintons
brought to that country that has just
been robbed and pillaged by the American
ruling class and uh I think you can
still find it on YouTube maybe if you're
lucky we are change Haiti but but uh
absolutely mind-boggling how much
politicians have robbed that country
particularly the clintons and just took
everything away from it uh just to add
up to the other points that we were
talking about before there's still
students that have to go through vax
mandates here in the United States that
still have to get their boosters uh
which is absolutely absurd in my opinion
did you did you guys know about the
story The the unlinked collar outbreak
was like a huge thing where I I remember
the full details but I remember there's
like a big expose about it where
basically something happened the UN
ended up contaminating a bunch of water
or something like that they say it was
cholera free until October 2010 when
infected sewage from United Nations
Keepers sent to the Caribbean Nation
after devastating earthquake
contaminated a river since that about 10
000 haits have died of the disease which
can cause profuse diarrhea and fluid
loss that can kill with hours more than
800 000 fell ill yeah it has a lot of
bad stuff that uh you know if you could
die from diarrhea I'd be dead 800 times
you can
yeah sir yes
that's how we ended up here
I wonder about stuff like the Silsbee
stuff you know because in all
seriousness she was like the story said
she was convicted and um like what's
going on like what are they doing
what are they doing Luke how far do you
want to go down yeah
what can I say here like I could go but
like I don't know if you want me to go
now like listen and uh before we get too
conspiratorial this will be on the
members only segment but all you got to
do is look at rip uh Lizzie Macbeth uh
the queen and one of her best friends is
a guy named Jimmy Seville and Jimmy
Savile it's one of the most legendary
evil uh Predators there ever was and you
look at her son prince Andrew but but my
point being is with Jimmy Seville is
that he would supposedly take them on a
boat and we got to say this we can only
say some stuff on YouTube and do the
most heinous things to children so why
would a evil person want to have access
to a children well I mean it's either
just going to be a cool tutor a mentor
or mentee relationship or you want to
probably violently do something you guys
ever see that uh South Park episode
about the Super Adventure Club is that I
think that's what it was called someone
someone Google that Super Adventure Club
something like that or the Explorers
Club I think it's a South Park episode
and basically you think they're like
adventurers but they're actually just a
network of Peters that go and rape kids
yeah yeah that's kind of what happened
with Boy Scouts with a lot of this stuff
I mean that was a South Park episode by
the way that that's just you know
fiction fiction is well all it is well
there's a saying nobody likes
other kids except for their own so if
you're like a person that wants to be
around kids all day whether like you
know mentoring them I almost kind of
give a break to coaches because that's a
little different they want to be like
involved in the sports but I feel like
adults that want to be with other
people's kids
but Ryan knows better than me he's a
teacher this is what I can't stand like
you don't want to stretch it too far no
I don't know that's part of this a
similar narrative where it's like there
was a story of a firefighter who was
sitting on a plane in a window seat and
a little girl was sat next to him and
the stores came up and said you have to
move and he was like excuse me why and
they're like because you can't sit next
to this little girl and he was like why
what and they forced him to move and
there's a bunch of stories like that
this idea that simply because you're an
adult who wants to Mentor kids
automatically makes you an evil person
yes I don't think that yeah no I just
think it's dangerous to be like people
shouldn't want to be around kids no we
should keep the creepos and the pitos
away from kids and people should
actually be good stewards to you know
the future Generations no and I agree I
think we need more Mentor mentee
relationships but I'm just saying
pedophiles or Predators figure out ways
in order to ingratiate themselves with
kids so they use gymnastics or they use
whatever they can to get access to kids
that's because they're predators and so
that you know it was when I was a
teacher and a coach I would have kids go
hey you know
they'd say something about being a
friend I'm like I'm not your friend
um your teacher like I don't I don't
have kid friends you know like I have
adult friends but I don't want a 17 year
old friend right like I'm your teacher
I'm your coach there's a relationship
here but that's what this relationship
looks like and that's where and I'm you
know it's terrible all the different
molestation issues that we have in
schools but to your point if you are a
sexual predator you want to go work at a
school I mean you're going to go to
where the kids are Disney or I mean that
just happened recently again right yes
you know Disney talks about that yeah
their security is is they understand
that they have got to be one of the top
places in the world for where a
pedophile would go and it's you have to
protect kids and you have to know that
again
hold on I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't
remember interrupt but this was 10 hours
ago oh my gosh Disney and Publix
Employees among those accused of wanting
to abuse and groom children yeah so this
this guy is is this the one where the
cop is like it wouldn't be a sting
without Disney and then he mentions like
another Disney employs cut look I don't
fault Disney for this I think they're
kind of bad for a lot of other reasons I
don't blame them it's that these these
creeps these pitos these Predators know
kids these are kid places and that's why
they seek out these jobs also schools
and that's why it's crazy that when
we're like hey we got to be careful
there's a bunch of these creepy stories
we had a story the other day about a
teacher who got arrested for banging a
high school student we need to be
vigilant because the Predators are
trying to get into these schools but you
get banned from Twitter for bringing it
up and that's right and that's where
when you talk about these conversations
about sexually inappropriate material
with kids that's exactly what you have
to make sure isn't going on in the
classroom because look how quickly that
turns into grooming look how quickly
that turns into molestation and putting
kids in these positions and so that's
where we have to hold the line on this I
mean it's it's it is protection of kids
yeah but you have to understand this is
not the first time that this happened
with with Disney there there was a
number of Disney things that you could
look up and you could see a plethora of
news reports there's also the Franklin
cover-up there's also Larry Nasser
there's also Epstein Edward Heath Jimmy
Savile I think is the biggest one when
it comes to people being in the industry
of allegedly being in Children's
Entertainment and using that along with
the connections with the royal family to
do just the most god-awful things and
we're talking about Beyond hurting
children this guy was believing in some
like satanic entities was doing things
to dead bodies that I can't even step
out of the morgue yeah I can't a
family-friendly show here so I'm not
going to get into it but but we have to
understand that the FBI when it came to
Larry Nasser and Epstein helped and
aided and embedded this operation all
the way so when you look at the FBI now
targeting School parents who are showing
up at the teacher school boards who are
concerned about this type of activity it
really makes you wonder what really deep
down is happening here and when the FBI
is targeting parents in Virginia as as
it was definitely I talking to them
right domestic terrorists yeah I mean
and you know Alex was talking about this
earlier about how corn nated is it I
mean you look at the levels of
coordination where you literally have a
national teachers union that comes in
and and asks and the National School
Board Association asks for the FBI to
investigate parents at school board
meetings and you look at this and you go
okay if we're about protecting kids and
doing what's best for kids there's no
one's going to protect their kid more
than their mom and dad
and the further that we continue to box
them out the less they can protect be a
part of what they're what's going on
with their kids but the other part of it
is it's it is the complete destruction
of the family unit we want I mean again
as a teacher one of the things we always
limit we wanted more parents involved we
want more parents a parent-teacher
conference we want more parents talking
to you about their kids because it means
that they're going to get that full
support they're going to be supported
and everything that's going on not only
at school but at home but yet the left
once that separation and you've got
extremists and you have folks that are
actually doing it intentionally to get
in with kids and for grooming purposes
well even on blm's uh you know whatever
mission statement has said the
denuclearization that's right down to
the family unit but explain to me this
so when they when you do the
standardized test now they say like a
sixth grader now is that like a first
grade level or something and they're
blaming that on the pandemic which I'm
sure that had a big part of it but are
kids just getting Dumber I mean why are
they doing so bad on the standardized
tests compared to not that long ago yeah
you know I I the entire system has been
built in a way that doesn't reward
exceptionalism and doesn't reward word
student outcomes whether that's
rewarding teachers or whether that's
getting kids more aligned to the
education that best fits their needs and
so what happens is again the national
teachers union fought to shut down
schools and masks yeah and fought to put
to mandate masks fought for all this
nonsense and then we have it and it
plays out and you see the disruption and
a school system I mean our education
system was already not performing well
and then you have the disruption which
is just further indicative of the entire
problem the entire problem is you have
associations that are far left that
their concern is not kids it is their
adult membership so guess what every
time we can fight to close down schools
they close down schools the national
teachers union every time they have a
reason to shut down a school a protest I
mean I've always think about a teacher
blocking kids from going to school and
that was what you saw during the
pandemic but it's indicative of the
policies they advocate for all the time
are not pro-student they're Pro their
associate and their name Pro teacher
really it's Pro their association their
membership to grow them and leverage
them and so the outcomes that you've
seen are because of intentionally and
they're and but I'm sorry you got me on
a rant right you teamed me up but the
other thing is their entire world view
is anathema to student performance if
you believe that everybody is a victim
okay if you believe that because of your
victim status because America is an evil
racist country misogynist I mean pick
every you know every box that they that
they try to check
and you tell kids that from when they're
three years old to when they're 18
you've built in every excuse to not be
successful not be successful and there's
a reason why you know again my other hat
was a coach as a coach you don't come in
and go hey we're going to get whooped
because that team you know hey they got
more money than us their Gym's nice on
us it doesn't matter you see athletes
come out of poverty all the time and
just kick people's butts because they
haven't been told from when they're
three hey
you know actually you know we live in a
in a bad part of town so you're never
going to be a good athlete that's not at
all what they're told but we do it in
academics because the left has been able
to take it over so they emphasize
victimization excuse making and kids
respond to that they rise to the level
of expectations you put on them and if
you tell them they're victims cool I've
got to get out of jail card for the rest
of my life because I'm a victim but
they'll be really good at dancing when
they're older because you know that's
one thing they're doing talking and I
don't want to you know Bogart the
conversation I don't Bogart the blunt I
don't want to Bogart the show but uh
Norm Macdonald has a great joke where he
talks about how teachers jobs are pretty
easy because both of his parents are
teachers and how I know these are going
to get mad because you're a teacher but
basically it's like you know it's like
low stakes and that they get all these
holidays and I think that's kind of
where it has it maybe people become
teachers because they know it's easy you
know I know not saying that it's easy to
teach I think it's hard to teach but
it's just kind of like this like a
teacher can almost be an alcoholic like
there's no high stakes for them to
actually teach their kids the curriculum
they're just kind of showing up and
getting a lot of videos yeah they're
they're the ones that showing the grades
they can say whatever they want yeah
they can be like buddy was good and the
lockdowns and the mask policies that
they caused had tremendous negative
effects not only on intelligence not
only on cognitive function but also
obesity there are many studies out right
now showing how these deliberate
lockdowns these deliberate maskings when
they weren't even backed by science have
had horrible tremendous negative effects
on the development on children or even
low what's her name Lee or Lena when on
uncnn came out publicly and said um I
should have never told my child to wear
masks because now he has developmental
problems because and I'm living proof
I've gained 45 pounds of YMCA kicked me
out for not wearing a mask let me back
in YMCA if you're watching this yes I
didn't on Preston Road in Dallas Texas
please let me back in but I don't think
you're you're you're I lost I gained the
weight because of them it's other fault
it's nothing to do with those milkshakes
you're innocent yeah the milkshakes
drank themselves that's true you're a
big booty uh I'm a big white guy
conspiracy theorist I love it yeah well
that's where we're at I did I can blame
the pandemic for everything uh uh but
we're back to the teachers I'm just
saying I think the like the idea of like
uh teachers actually caring about their
students they don't care about that they
care more about their social issues and
like teaching these kids that you know
white guilt and uh yada yada yeah we're
not championing excellence and outcomes
we're not saying that the goal of
educate these groups are not saying the
goal of education is to get a kid in a
position to get a job that lines up with
their talent with their skill sets so
that they can get the most out of their
life that's not listen to the arguments
we don't feel safe so we don't want
schools to open well we've got all the
science that says that it is safe well
no well we still don't feel safe well if
you don't give us x x y or Z we're going
to close down the school so I mean
frankly what are you doing
the kids are held hostage in this in
this agreement here with the national
teachers union so we're not going to let
your kids get an education until you
give our association what we want I mean
you just see how how we flip the whole
thing on his head and if the argument is
what's best for kids and what puts them
in the best spot to be successful
frankly
you want to have good teachers you want
to have folks in the classroom that are
exceptional that are ambitious that are
talented that are that work well in that
environment that solve complex problems
but you know what when you create a
system that says actually we don't care
actually what we want to do is make sure
our association's happy what you're
doing is just setting a baseline for
saying we're just going to make this as
easy as possible rather than hey we want
to find exceptionalism I want to make
sure that people are being successful
because that means that the kids will be
better off
I'm a big fan of the micro schools uh we
had one we have one out here that I've
I've contributed to the way they do it
is your your grade level is based on
where you are so if you complete the
entire math book then you're done with
math yeah can we even talk about that
for a second think about how silly this
is
you're in you're in seventh grade well
what if you get through with all the
seventh grade material or you're in
seventh grade yeah okay what if you're
bad at math one good at English 45
minutes in math 45 minutes English well
I struggle with English 45 minutes in
English I mean the way we've set up the
entire system is to not be flexible to
not be agile and are you familiar with
like the maker spaces micro schools
where they give kids like a maker space
and say hey yeah so oh it's awesome and
they go here's the deal you've got to
create a project that does a b or c boom
you got three weeks to do it wow and
they and they give them the materials
and go hey here you go and it's it's
based on the project this is where again
the over standardization of saying hey
you've got to get 36 credits and you got
to get a physics credit you got to do
these 45 things every week today no no
what do we want what do we want what's
the end game work with the indie game in
line and what do you want for kids and
those maker spaces have been just
blowing up you compare that to children
learning about pronouns it's a no it's a
no-brainer there's another article from
NBC News in 2004 that really kind of is
very eye opening it kind of hits on what
we're talking about and it's titled
study one in 10 students encounter sex
abuse in school this is NBC News
according to research from the
Department of Education after quote
exhaustive review of research and those
numbers are absolutely crazy in 2004 I
could only imagine what's possibly even
happening right now
we're gonna unless anyone wants to wrap
up I want to do a hard segue another
hard Segway the story on Newsweek
Dan Crenshaw gets a defeated clash with
right wing comedian about war what uh so
is there anybody here who has any
experience or something like this maybe
someone could shine a light on what's
this all about with Dan Crenshaw well
actually you know you're not pulling up
this clip at Marjorie Taylor green my
queen she just got confronted by some uh
you know anti-second Amendment
protesters and I was yeah I know when I
was coaching her you can actually pull
it up on her Twitter I think she
retweeted it but but I was basically
saying so we're about to show this
Crenshaw uh you know interaction but I
had just seen I just saw I don't even
know their proper verbiage but I you
probably know Ryan but I had just
interacted with Eric swalwell and Eric
swalwell when I said hey Fang Fang I
heard she gave you Insertion I heard you
guys had an affair he kept his head down
and didn't engage with the troll which
is that's what you should do Tim you
don't want to get in the mud with Prime
Time 99 but Dan Crenshaw has the
thinnest skin he just has to get in the
mud with a pig like me so watch this I
mean I mean you just can't you couldn't
have hoped of me it's almost low hanging
fruit it this point I don't even want to
go after Crenshaw anymore I almost feel
I'm a little empathetic to I'm not
sympathetic but like I kind of feel his
pain he just sucks everybody knows he
sucks right what happened to that guy
you know well I mean he voted to kick
people out of the you know Army Reserves
a national guard for not being
inoculated he gets angry at little girls
calling him out yeah you know
when he first started people were like
okay you know I kind of like this guy
what's going on and then he kind of just
went off well and the rumor is that the
latest Trump event uh the Trump rally he
waited to get a photo up and Trump
didn't want to photo up with him so it's
just he's a globalist he cares more
about the border between Ukraine and
Russia and we'll watch this uh and
that's what I'm saying is and I want to
make this point clear before this video
plays he's trying to go after me with
this narrative that I'm anti-veterans
first of all I care about our veterans I
care about every single serviceman that
has ever had to put on the uniform that
person within the uniform I care about
and I support wholeheartedly but some of
the actions that the uniform takes that
people in charge I think that we're
fighting wars in the Middle East for
weapons of mass destruction that did not
exist we have things called the Baka
Bazi boys where they're actually Rich
Afghanistan men all over raping young
little kids over and over and our our
army official narrative was oh well
there are there are allies so let's not
get and they punish the people who
whistleblowed on that situation the
soldiers that said hey this is crazy
this should stop immediately they talk
to the media they got punished I think
there's no more just reason to start a
war and I'm as anti-war as it gets but
if you told me there's a country of just
all pedophiles attacking children then
I'd say hey and I'm as anti-wars against
I say hey maybe we go get involved with
that but the idea that you know this war
was just or that these people were sent
over to the Middle East with a clear
objective nobody can prove that and you
can just see it but I'd like to make
this last point if you look at our
withdrawal from Afghanistan with people
hanging from the wheel well of airplanes
you look at them just you know ruining
80 billion dollars of military equipment
just like running over the guns with the
tank they didn't care about in the first
place if they showed that sort of lack
of Care on top of drone striking and
murdering about four children that same
week so if that shows you that is the
type of care and pursue seizures and
protocols that they took that took place
in the Middle East it was not justified
in anything that was an aid worker that
they said was Isis XL or something I
want to point this out um Dan Crenshaw
basically said you were shaming a group
of veterans and it's and it seems like
just the the anybody who watched the
video
can conclude that you were talking
specifically about war hawks War mongers
people voting for needless Wars and then
his only response was to be like you
hate veterans and it's just like dude
you like
that's that's the problem I have with
so much of the establishment there's no
engagement they know that if they
actually engage on the issues they lose
on the issues so they just say things
like you're racist you're sexist you
hate veterans Etc well just look at the
Vietnam War I mean that was unjust I
don't know the last war that we had that
was even justifying I guess World War II
people will say but my point being is
there's no justifiable reason in my
opinion I know there's other people say
oh we have to start a war I think you're
kind of you know there's reasons to have
War but for me just to kill people when
we have that that thing that makes us
different from animals you know we
should be able to come to some sort of
agreement we don't have to murder
everybody but these people do not care
like Dan Crenshaw all he cares about is
a military-industrial complex he cares
about Halliburton cares about Raytheon
because they're going to donate money to
his political action committee that is
going to keep him in office so once you
are bought and sold by these
corporations you don't care about the
thousands hundreds of thousands of young
men that are getting sent to fight Wars
for Bankers or for imaginary lines in
the sand that don't benefit the American
people if you want to do something with
our troops put them on the southern
border and start helping you know the
people that are facing drug and sex
trafficking issues every day why is it
that the uh the guy who described
himself before the show is an idiot and
and a comedian is making better points
about politics than Dan Crenshaw could
when asked about it it's because I was
dropped on my head as a baby that's why
I'm autistically smart I'm Like Rain Man
I can see the Rain Man a little bit no
no but I think every
board in the Middle East was not
justified and so for him trying to be
like oh well you're anti-fiction I'm not
I want to do more to help her veterans
our veterans are treated absolutely
terrible there's a huge suicide rate
that you know very rarely gets very much
attention and I think it's similar to
the opioid epidemic that we're going
through the veterans I don't care about
and the people that die fennel overdoses
they don't care about yeah and now the
US Army is telling them to go on SNAP
benefits and food stamps literally to
deal with inflation yeah you could pull
up the story right now look up active
service US Army SNAP benefits and the
story will pull up it's a crazy story
that absolutely should make people
reconsider and they wonder why
recruitment numbers are so low well
first of all there's so much propaganda
look at this story Tim and we're hiring
87 000 IRS agents to go after people
that are making under 400k to get around
about 20 billion dollars It's The End
come on and they're telling American
soldiers to do this you cannot convince
me that we have a country capable of
survival when our army is being told to
go on food stamps
like that's that's just it that's just
it when when when the government itself
can't pay its own military and suggests
food stamps
ah we're done but uh yeah like this is
just one sign but it's a big sign that's
a big it's a big red flag and it's got a
sickle and a hammer on it yeah well I
mean idiocracy I know we always talk
about that as a fictional movie but it's
it's pretty real once the more the
federal government gets involved in
something the more they screw it up so I
mean you know and it's it's history
right it's Rome I mean this is Rome Rome
did not take care of their army they
ended up having to hire mercenaries to
carry out their never-ending Wars that
they want to keep on going and they
treated their own soldiers so bad they
couldn't even staff it so they had to go
and hire mercenaries man but this is
it's terrible yeah yeah but at least uh
free transgender surgery to any soldier
that wants to transition well there's
that so look
the Army's getting whoa the Navy's
getting woke people are retiring
resigning recruitments way way down and
Vex mandates and Vex mandates and now
food stamps and they're like why don't
people want to join the Army bro when
that commercial came out where the girl
was like I have two moms I was just
sitting here being like and what does
that have to do with being in the Army
yeah yeah but this is the biggest scam
Tim is how they get people to join the
Army for the GI Bill and there's just
such a funny meme but it's so dark and
it's like a guy you know his first day
like in boot camps like I joined the
army for free college and then the next
picture it's a guy like you know with a
gun you know in the full military outfit
about to shoot like an Afghanistan guy
he's like please don't shoot me in the
guy holding the gun in the military guys
like I need free college so I'm saying
that you know they basically trick
people into getting free college into
becoming literal warmongers for banks so
I I think I don't like the I guess I
don't like the carrot that they use
because they should make school more
accessible we should take that Meme
where it's like a guy and he's in he's
in like the Army and he's like shivering
and like you know the cold or he's in
like a desert sweating and then there's
like people shooting at him and then
he's like just remember the eyes keep
your eyes on the prize after all of the
second free college and the next one is
some like you know fat dude eating
Doritos being like Biden just forgave
myself yeah exactly yeah and I don't
even fault to people for taking the ten
thousand dollars our government is so
dumb uh you know because that's what
everybody said oh well you took out a
PPP loan first of all our government is
is so mismanaged and I think it's a one
percent of the population has 99 of the
wealth so if the government will help
you out 50 I think it's is that whatever
it is they got most of it they're
they're hoarding everything so if the
government wants to give you a break I
say take it it's not going to be fair we
have an unfair system so let's just try
not to make it divide us and hate each
other over it too much I think you know
I was thinking about the student loan
forgiveness thing and I was like why is
it going to matter when the system
collapses it goes back to zero yeah well
it's like fighting what is it what is it
Freddie May or whatever is it Freddie
Mac Freddie Mac there you go I don't
think the agents are going to come to
your house after the apocalypse happens
they're going to be like Yo's money from
that degree well and feel like okay dude
but Tim and Fight Club I think the end
of it is they they uh like you know
Tyler Durden has the secret group but
they wanted to blow up all the credit
card companies and get rid of the credit
card debt it's kind of similar to that
right right wipe out all the files
because then everyone goes back to zero
yeah and then and that but but that's
not actually a good thing no you know so
like the problem is they're they're we
do have a problem with every like
massive debt but debt between people
isn't always a bad thing like that means
people owe each other and they're going
to work for each other and labor is
going to persist yeah but I got to make
this last morning but when they took us
off a gold system now me owing the
government a hundred thousand dollars
means the government's worth a hundred
thousand dollars so it doesn't make
sense nothing backs our whole financial
system it literally is redundant no uh
we have guns
I don't know I don't know I mean we tell
people around the world you use our
money or else yeah that's true because
moamer Gaddafi tried to take uh he tried
to turn Libya on the African dinar and
uh and and Hillary Clinton and we came
we saw he died
you know and yep to your point about the
student loan issue the more the
government subsidizes higher ed the more
we don't get to have the real discussion
and have the market pressures about what
is a college degree worth we are getting
further and further away from making
them face that question because the
reality is I don't know it depends on it
depends on what type of degree it is it
depends on the market value of the
degree
um and frankly that needs to be a
national discussion do we need higher ed
for all of these different degree
Pathways can we not start certifying
this and guess what yeah start opening
this up for more Americans where you can
actually go get these type of jobs by
showing that you're competent and have
the ability to be trained to do this
when I talk to folks you know in the
business Community they even talk about
that as well hey I'd rather have a young
person let them come in here let's let
them learn let me train them let me work
with them rather than get them four or
five years down the road six figures in
debt with a degree that frankly I don't
know the degree equates to helping out
in our job hey if you're good at what
you do and you learn and you work well
with others or you've got good ideas get
in here and let's go let's uh let's jump
to this story we got this tweet that
Alex has mentioned rep Marjorie Taylor
green she said These Foolish cowards
want the government to take away guns
and the rights of parents to defend
their children in schools you have to be
an idiot to think gun control will
create a utopian society where criminals
disarm themselves and obey the law let's
play this and see exactly what happens
after I get all this media they're like
oh let's go hang out with it and I'm I'm
not the first person to do this so I
don't care you're allowed to I like the
copycats my point being is you're right
he's not doing good he doesn't have the
selfie stick he doesn't have the uh
hutzpah as they say he doesn't have and
he doesn't have he doesn't know what
he's talking about yeah he's not even
he's not even passionate
I want to live in a country where kids
don't get shot he just keeps saying the
same thing over again like bro nobody
wants to live in a country where kids
are getting shot and like we're actively
trying to stop this but all you do is
you're like we should have a gun-free
zone and it's like then what do we do
when the kids get shot call the guys
with guns to tell them to come that's
insane dude yeah and when they take away
the guns only people have the guns or
the cops military criminals so I mean
it's like we want to create a place
where there's no guns what happens if
someone walks past that sign you better
call the guy with a gun why don't we
have a guy with a gun there no no it's a
gun-free zone okay you know what dude
it's like the energy thing they're like
carbon emissions are bad we have nuclear
power no nuclear you can't do why you
know it's bad why is it bad yeah
whatever okay okay well you're not
they're not offering Solutions they're
offering problems and you know why
probably because when they make more
problems they can vote to say the ones
who are going to solve the problems and
they just make more problems
yeah I think you get a really strong
point I mean uh they it's when I get
when I walk and I go through DC there's
this weird energy of just red tape like
they want more crap to complain about or
to like they need it yeah that's why
they don't want to let racism go and
they never want a solution to your point
they never want a solution because they
can always create the fear and create
the enemy the reality is one of the
things we've done in Oklahoma we're
keeping pushing for other schools to do
this put a big sign out in front of the
school that says some staff here are
armed and if you enter here to hurt kids
they will use all forces necessary to
take you out there you go hey you don't
know who it is you don't know where it
is but guess what you're not going to
come into our schools and attack our
kids you're not going to do it and you
know or you can have the opposite which
is what we've seen other places around
the country basically put up a big sign
that goes don't worry there is no one
here with a gun and we've got the most
precious asset possible our kids and
don't worry there's no gun by the way
that that's the craziest thing to me
yeah it's absurd so have you seen the
veritas thing where they would go door
to door and they were like you know do
you favor gun control and they're like
yes like would you be willing to put up
a sign in your yard saying proud gun
free mom and they're like no and he was
like why not and they were like because
we'd be inviting criminals and they were
like are you saying you think you need a
gun to defend yourself and they're like
uh it's just anti-com it's just common
sense it's not it's not anything you
know it's not rocket science it's just
common sense what is this you know Alex
I did notice earlier I was just gonna
ask Alex if you know a water drop gone
on you and then you kind of like got
shaken and then a gremlin troll came out
and that was that guy who was terrible
yeah yeah I'm sorry but that was only my
point is I saw Alex over there uh with
this uh you know kind of doing the
selfie routine earlier look at the angle
there is he even getting them and that's
what I'm saying
when it comes to confronting these
politicians if you're not passionate
about this guy it's just it's just kind
of a dud and I was giving Marjorie some
some pointers I think that you have to
not engage a little bit maybe engage in
because you want to act like you're on
the same level but that's what I talked
about when I first went to like City
Council meetings and I would speak
seriously they wouldn't and I think you
should engage
my point because what I want to do when
I told them is I want them to engage so
you want to engage with what the person
doesn't want you to say does that make
sense like you like if as a politician
you want to engage with them well I just
want to shut them down with like a
softball question I'm like hey how's
your day going hey you know you're a
really great person and then they let
their guard down and then I would hit
them
those legendary stuff you know he
wouldn't confronted Larry Silverstein
too Larry so I mean that is one of the
most Rockefeller right you got
Rockefeller Rock child's bigger
Brzezinski Henry Kissinger a bunch of
times
and Luke Luke's been to Epstein Island
Tony Blair bill and Al Gore we made Al
Gore cancel his book tour I think he
missed that one too wow wow you guys
think it's a big deal little Dan
Crenshaw five foot three like yeah right
that's nothing compared to what Luke's
done so I'm gonna kiss your butt a
little bit normally when I say that Luke
spent Epstein Island he corrects it
really quick but this time I'm tired I'm
tired of this [ __ ] well he also went to
Zoro ranch in New Mexico and uh oh did
you go to that big owl statue too no
yeah
he said you were his date here's what I
want to say I want to go I want to go
back to the uh the troll stuff I think
the reason it works is because none of
these people actually know how to deal
with it and if it were me look I
understand like you're on your way
somewhere and so like marjorie's clearly
like got something to do but for me I
actually would just stop and be like
what's up yeah I agree I think you do
need to engage him a little bit but my
point being is kind of smart and cunning
yeah I let him talk and then I'd be like
you want me to answer and then I'll try
to answer just playing a Troll game I
just be calm about it and be like
and then just be like I'll answer you
know whatever you ask me a question I
think the issue is that especially for
people like Crenshaw the only thing he
could say was well you hate veterans
because he didn't have anything to say
he didn't have an argument to make
anybody who's arguing that the the wars
in the Middle East were a mistake is
right is they are correct and like the
over only majority of people in this
country agree with that so how do you
defend being in favor of War today when
most people are like we don't want to be
involved in this garbage anymore Tim
Ukraine it was like seamless all of a
sudden we went from we're out of
Afghanistan now we're just spending
billions and billions and billions of
dollars to the you know proxy war in
Ukraine killing Russians from you know
our money it they have to continue to
keep these wars going and it's just so
blatantly obvious but sadly everybody is
asleep they have no idea what's really
happening
how do you wake them up
I don't know but you yell at people and
call them big booties yeah I mean
sometimes well that's the other thing is
too when you're taking a nap and
somebody shakes and wakes you up from
the nap then you're like mad at the
person for waking you up so it's really
hard I think with me and this is me
talking personally when I tried to wake
people up and I'm sure Luke might have
had the same thing it's kind of hard
people don't want to know you know that
information because it's deep you have
to put a lot of time into it and it's
kind of negative vibrational energy it
puts you in this bad headspace but for
me what's been effective in making
people question the reality is comedy
and you said earlier that they don't
have Solutions well I think they do it's
a hegelian dialectic where they do have
Solutions called Problem reaction
solution but the solution that we have
that we want and what they want is so
different and they have a saying is you
know the ends justify the means so it's
like we need that we need to kind of do
the same thing kind of like the Saul
linsky's Rules for Radicals and in that
one of the things is whatever you do
wrong or whatever you get accused of
accuse the accuser of the same thing and
that's what we have to do is we kind of
have to use their rules against them and
create the solution that we want where
kids you know are not being
indoctrinated and then we kind of use
the hegelian dialectic against the New
World Order well for me personally just
being happy healthy and prosperous is an
act of resistance in our modern day
society and if you could be an example
of that and if you could lead by example
that's one of the biggest things you
could do open the door you can't push
people through because the more you do
the more you're going to have a negative
effect with it and I I think leading
with Solutions celebrating our victories
and just admitting yes we're living in
very tumultuous crazy times but but
these times also provide us an
opportunity to challenge ourselves and
make us the best version of ourselves
that we could create right now with this
huge uphill battle that seems impossible
but in that in that Journey we're going
to learn and have a lot of incredible
learning lessons that are going to stay
with us for the rest of our lives
did we learn from the pandemic no I know
that's brilliant but a lot of people
have a lot of people have learned from 9
11. they learn from Iraq and again it's
a balance yin and yang there's negative
forces there's positive forces in this
world which one are you going to give
your energy towards right so so I think
it's it's a choice that we all make
constantly and I think if we focus on
helping people not being victims because
there's a lot of victims and if we could
prevent people from being victims of the
next psyup of the next mind control of
the next uh scam that's going to be
hitting people that's a huge victory in
itself and it's up to the person
themselves to decide if they're going to
be a victim or if they're going to be
thriving in this world it's your choice
many people are doing like survival
training I am and and there's a huge
interest in it and there's been there's
been a lot of classes that have been
selling out all over the country with
individuals doing these types of
trainings because one it's fun and and
two it's great to have a skill that you
could actually offer to a community that
would be wonderful even if if ish hits
the fan you will be prepared no matter
what that's why I started apocalypse
survival uh part of my program on we are
james.org it's funny they said ish hits
the fan yeah so it just sounded like you
said fish hits the fan you sound like
you said
hey family I still said it in a
family-friendly way that's right little
kids are watching so we're trying to you
know well speaking of family friendly
this is why we should all be very
worried I just saw a clip of The
Simpsons and they're all you know
building bug out bags and they had the
apocalypse and it was all from emp's
electromagnetic pulses that knocked
everything offline so I'm saying if it
happened on The Simpsons it's probably
gonna happen in real life she'll get
some rice get some beans you know just
cyber cyber polygon cyber polygon is the
is the is the war game that the world
economic Forum did with Russia with the
United States uh going through hacking
of infrastructure emps and uh a whole
bunch of important uh online
um infrastructure going down all at once
so they practice this this is a war game
that they could it would just be
you know in some ways exciting just to
wake up in the morning and like there's
no electricity like nothing turns Yeah
Tim because you can open up a KFC he's
got a chicken City he's gonna have he's
gonna have chicken
we have 126 eggs from like a week
I'm like we got too many chickens it's
just so many and the thing is chickens
make more chickens if you
'll totally put food in there one of our
chickens was brooding we had to stop her
because it's too late this season and
then it's like now we got some Jersey
Giants we just bought because they're
big but we I'm like we got too many
chickens and then in the springtime
they're gonna keep making more of
themselves it's like we don't even do
anything you know they they just walk
around they eat stuff and then I come
out there and there's more of them it's
great then you got to eat some of them I
guess all right we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends
and you got to become a member at
timcast.com because you can already tell
this members only segment is going to
get ridiculous it's going to be very
ridiculous so I think we'll just talk
all crazy conspiracy stuff it'll be a
good time timcast.com smash the like
button I'm going to jump to this Super
Chat real quick because I saw it a while
ago
your mom said hi says shout out to me
Kyle Bobby and Tyler we just did the one
chip challenge don't do it do you guys
know what that is the one yeah with
those super hot chips I bought a bunch I
got them they're downstairs okay so I'll
do one I'll do it and you're complaining
about mud butt yeah
I will eat someone bring it up last jar
get it up bring it stand up to chip
Chris if you're listening
Chris you're listening to this come up
with the chips
legit yeah I'm Not Afraid this is if I
don't live in fear the trauma-based Mind
Control doesn't work on my brain or my
b-hole I don't care I will drink it
you're gonna feel it twice just so you
know Hey listen twice as nice I don't
care
I uh I will do anything I'm on the grind
all the time I'm making the call I'm the
human you want to do it you wanna yes I
want to eat a chip on here I'm gonna
start sweating I'm gonna start crying
have you not you've seen The Tick Tock
videos you know where this is
how far is the hospital no it's hot it's
hot it's hot hotter the better I want it
hot I want it apparently like we opened
it and sniffed it and went oh okay well
let me tell you something about sniffing
this isn't a hunter Biden episode
this is a Primetime 99 Packy chip is
that what it's called the pack eye chip
challenge or something like that this is
not going to end well but you know it's
this is a this is one uh life advice for
me and remember I am not a role model
but guys in life none of us make it out
alive so just you know that's just one
thing life is short it is I don't think
we're gonna be able to get it oh my God
I would I would have to go down and get
it myself personally why why because
it's locked in the car
oh Packy challenge after show I can I
can see if uh I can I can I know you
want to do it on the air well we got it
we gotta we still got a half an hour let
me okay let me see how you figure this
out because you know or someone else
could read super chats while you go yeah
that's a possibility too I want to go
why don't why don't you go run down and
okay okay whose car uh Luke wait hold on
laid back Luke
can you I'm gonna eat so much Hot Chip
I'm gonna uh all right here's what you
gotta do you gotta find Chris got it
okay I'm gonna go go give the inside
baseball mute this we don't want you and
then you know what they look like
they're they're little blue coffins will
help me find them so I don't need I
don't even know if Chris knows what it
looks like but they're a little blue
coffins they might be in the the Honda
okay so ask Chris they might be in the
house in a bag I don't know whether we
have five of them okay I'm not
responsible whatever happens
we're doing this this is all about
content and this is uh
and this is this is let me tell you
something to wash it down I have a Quest
Bar because and we're not sponsored but
tonight we've gone on a you know a
mission quest for truth and hot sauce
and uh pain I have a feeling it's gonna
be like 20 minutes and he's gonna be
like I can't figure out where it is
because I don't even know where they are
we we went to uh where do we go oh we
went to Blue Ridge Rock Fest and I was
at 7-Eleven and they had them and
they're a bunch of kids there and
they're like don't do it and then I was
like I'm doing it get out I said that to
you that was just unsolicited they said
well they saw that we grabbed them and
they were like don't do an old man see
kid's nose and I was like
seven
we would eat in Chicago we need bachi's
pizza
dude that is it's like this big I don't
know it's like massive slice and it's
five bucks oh slice yeah it's a huge
slice I don't know if they still exist
anymore and then they would have eating
contests and like to qualify to eat two
of them and I had a group of friends
that wanted to qualify for eating
contest so they went in they bought two
slices they ate them and then they were
like all right you qualified they walked
outside just barfed in the alley yeah
there's too much in their guts yeah and
then there was this woman that won I
think she's like a little Asian when
they call her the Black Widow I think
people know of like the her she's like a
famous eater or something I don't know
yeah I know but listen I can eat a lot
I've been banned from multiple all you
can eat buffets in Dallas Texas oh yeah
not just for eating but they have a very
you know they're very strict about their
egg roll policy if you try to put some
in your pockets and walk out that's not
fair that's not allowed at the Dallas
Buffet I thought that was legal we
should like should we get like a glass
of milk ready or like no I mean just
water I don't I mean listen I'm gonna
get I'm gonna go insane for the Ukraine
I'm probably gonna cry a little bit but
let's not I mean like I said we want to
kind of amp it up I'm a very well here's
what's a razzle dazzle with it you know
what I mean he's hoping he finds it man
all right let's read some more Super
chats
oh right it did you find it right now
okay okay okay okay might be in the car
oh I don't know it might be on the floor
in the living room or something Alex is
having seconds no I'm not I'm gonna eat
it no matter what I'm not gonna be a
little [ __ ] ass dude these are these
are like I don't even know if it's
actually it's like I don't even know how
to call it a chip the Scoville level is
illegal in the state so uh yeah really
well let's let's read here Raymond juice
Stanley Jr says Tim as a translucent
skeletal skulled sea freak hearing you
get so excited talking about Fast and
Furious makes me want a siren it's all
about family
yo
this is what I'm saying Fast and Furious
they went to outer space and the last
one you guys saw that and then in Hobbs
and Shaw it just almost got super powers
I'm saying we got to do one of two
things and the next Fast and the Furious
I think I think they should have
Megazords like the cards should come
together make a giant robot oh oh yeah
that's yeah like I like it giant robot
fighting another giant robot and then
the next one fast 11 they should be
driving in like a nuclear-powered fusion
Future car and then the engine
malfunctions and it explodes and all of
the fast crew gets blasted by Space
Magic and they get super powers what and
then Vin Diesel's like flying around and
he's like shooting lasers like Superman
I'm not kidding I would I would pay I
would pay double to see that movie not
even kidding who wins in a fight though
could Vin Diesel defeat Optimus Prime I
don't know that's what I want to see
dude he's gonna be like yo I'm gonna
race you and Optimus is like Dom you
can't race me and he's like watch me and
and then he's flying and then see that's
not how he does it that's not how you
don't need it real quick I know how
everybody you gotta admit it if they
made a movie of a super powered Dom from
Fast and the Furious fighting Optimus
Prime people would pay 50 bucks to go
see that no you had to do the Jeffrey
Epstein what happens is
he seduces Optimus Prime and then he
gets him on tape shoving like Toyota
you have to oil it up a little bit so
he's going to jam a Toyota Camry up that
Vin Diesel does that and then he puts it
on camera and now Optimus Prime has to
do whatever Vin Diesel says because he
has leverage on him so I think I think
actually what would be I would watch it
what would make more sense though is
like Optimus Prime goes to Vin Diesel
and he's like Dom we must race to defeat
Megatron and he's like for the family
and then they high five and then he's
like racing the semi and Megatron's like
I will defeat you and then Starscream is
there and you know Transformers and
Bumblebee well and we got to be careful
can we say Transformers on YouTube I
feel like there's a very popular movie
series yeah okay you know we can do we
can do a crossover so we can have um
Mark Wahlberg in it and Shia LaBeouf and
they come together in the team up with
the Fast and Furious crew and Leah
Thomas and they go to outer space and
then they get and then they should get
fantastic Ford where like the sun
explodes and they get super powers I'm
just saying yo they've they sent the
fast crew to outer space so I'm just
ready I'm ready for more let's read some
more Super chats let's read some more
otherwise you know I'll keep talking
about Fast and the Furious yeah it's the
best it really is it's the best movie
all right Iggy the incubus says George
takai compared the migrants being
delivered to Martha's Vineyard to
Auschwitz hilarious correct oh it's just
so cringe CNN their commentary was also
gold
oh man
all right all right
Matt McCartney says who dictates when
the government is tyrannical and what
qualifying factors must be met before a
well-armed militia can lawfully
overthrow said government
I don't I don't think there's an answer
to that and I think that's why
you know uh
I don't think there's an answer to it
that's why there's fear of Civil War
because there isn't one what I will say
is I I think you all got to be careful
we're so close to a major victory in the
midterms and it's very clear that what
the what the doj what the Democrats and
what the what the left wants is
desperately for the right to get violent
because the old saying is that when you
get the governor knows how to deal with
you but when you're peaceful and you
play you use the system to your to your
best of your abilities like registering
your friends to vote and voting they
can't do anything about that and they're
panicking because of it well the state
has a monopoly of violence and it's
their main tool that they use to
Galvanize power and control everyone you
don't want to use their own tools
against them and can I say one thing on
that you know what I think is you know
the left loves to do this where they do
something extreme and over the top and
then the right responds and then they
get put in a position you're crazy why
would you react this way and what
they're doing right now to president
Trump they are actively trying to foment
some outrage on the other side and so I
think that's a great point but you know
something we've talked about a little
bit tonight is
our kids understanding American history
and understanding why that second
amendment is there understanding that
the government only has the power that
we have given over to it that's that's
how this works because we're getting to
a place where you start seeing this
Reliance on the government the lack of
understanding where the government
derives its power from and the
understanding of why that second
amendment was so crucial in having this
entire experiment work in government but
again I think this is so key to helping
us understand moving forward moving out
of this massive overreach during covid
to understand that this is what happens
when you give the government too much
power and assume that that the um I'm
like you know the the government gets to
set the rules the government doesn't set
the rules the people set the rules the
government has to abide by those rules
and the way they're set Tim I like your
optimism but are you not really just I
mean does it matter when you know that a
deep state that tried to impeach Trump
two times I mean does it even matter if
you take control you know oh yeah yeah
look how desperate they've become dude
look at all the people that are winning
look at right now there's I think
there's 200 Trump endorsed candidates
who won their primaries what we're
seeing now with them going after abandon
it's it's they want you to think they're
in Invincible they want you to think you
can't do anything because we are less
than two months away from a major ground
gaining political maneuver maybe you
know it's not gonna be the executive
branch but you might actually see it
with 200 Trump endorsed candidates that
means the the Trump Republicans are
going to have more they're not gonna
have the majority of Congress they're
gonna have the majority of the
Republican party and so neocon
Republicans are going to have to vote
with Democrats it is going to be insane
when we end up seeing like the
Republican party just going nuts I think
you might but you're going to see
committees controlled by Trump
supporting Republicans Trump endorse
candidates I think two months what they
desperately need they would love it if
Trump supporters and people on the right
did something acted a fool and that's
why what you got to do now is you gotta
you gotta raise your fist and knock on
the door politely and then wave to your
neighbor and say have you registered to
vote no you're right we have to be
civilly disobedient and not break the
law but who wins Oz or federal can you
open the door and oz are fetterman in
Pennsylvania
yeah here we go
oh my God
oh really but mine's mine was blue
oh get down here come on I see you're
playing this with your face
this is this is Chris Poole we got it
all right
all right Alex is gonna eat it
Chris you want to stand here
I love the symbology of a coffin that's
really sweet okay all right have you
ever seen have you ever seen Boondock
Saints I mean symbolism be of all time
okay I had to do the willing to focus
wow this is really taped on here read
the warning I'm gonna read it all no I
can't get in here so Chris actually had
his own oh caricity he just he just eats
him yeah he just says he like he opens
them up puts in the bag no he does not
oh my gosh okay look at the literature
oh boy wow oh my
destroyed this is not I destroyed I
don't like this no symbolism okay this
where's the chip what this is the chip
right here kind of like a condom it kind
of kind of Vibes I don't know a lot less
safe I think he's stalling no I'm not
face the reaper I'm facing come on good
this is content I agree I'm gonna pimp
on a blimp and I'm eating this for you
Dan Crenshaw I know you didn't like me
so this will hopefully the chat room is
going crazy
I'm not even watching the chat
[Applause]
I just want to say this is for all the
people locked up for January 6. you guys
I'm doing this for you guys I'm I'm
pouring one out for my homies and
um to my favorite big booty latina I eat
this chip for you Alexandria
ocasio-cortez or as I call you my sweet
angel
oh my gosh she did it he's gonna die
it's funny because like I'm watching
this and he's just eating a chip and I'm
like I don't know is it is it good it's
hot
it's pretty hot it's pretty hot so far
we have pretty hot Crunchy lip smacking
I love it really painful
it's just a kind of like a glassy
feeling like um glassy like a light bulb
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
wait the challenge is that you're not
supposed to drink any water for like an
hour or something what what like no no
look yeah look at it
there's there's ratings where it's like
if you can last one minute
yeah read those things
bring some milk Chris if you're
listening no the hiccups all of a sudden
oh my wow it's hot Alex is gonna die oh
and Luke was right you're gonna feel it
twice
Alex is dead
screw the challenge take some water
spray some milk Christmas
hey look look it says if you can last
five minutes you're powerless 10 minutes
is powerful 30 minutes of supercharge if
you last one hour you're Invincible did
you drink water already you got it you
gotta go one you gotta say he can't
drink anything he can't drink anything
they're supposed to for one hour okay
for one hour to get to be invincible
Alex gonna do some jumping jacks put
that energy to good use imagine people
nope are you really gonna puke right
there is it is it that bad
this is hot that's I mean bro if you
want to drink the water I'm not going to
stop you I think I have some raw Cosmic
milk downstairs yeah we have those
coffees over there that's pet milk it's
not for human consumption it's getting
hotter it's getting hotter that's great
it's your eat your question yep yep you
don't have to drink anything yeah but
you're gonna lose the challenge what no
wait the challenge doesn't stipulate
whether you're going to eat Quest Bars
that's true that's technically correct
let me read what it says it says how
long can you last before getting owned
eating or drinking anything oh my God
yeah so it's if you make it five minutes
you like you lose I guess Alex you got
this it's hot
all right you hang there grunting and
I'll read more Super chats it feels like
the devil's urinating in my mouth
all right all right Jeremy Hernan wait
wait wait wait wait Jeremy Herndon says
started late because BJJ class goes to
9pm but I haven't had this much fun
since Labonte and Jones were on the show
yeah we had we we were gonna have we had
Alex Jones and I was like Phil we need
someone who can like help us keep Alex
Jones you know contained and he's like
yeah yeah no I can do it and then and
then when Alex Jones started saying
stuff Phil just looks looks at him and
goes you yes I was like what are you
doing no
he like he set me up
how you doing I'm not doing well at all
just crying so I burned so bad
did it taste did it taste good kind of I
mean the flavor profile wasn't that bad
you're crying
oh it hurts
if I die maybe I'll go out of my pain a
little bit you can you can uh it's been
how long it's been three minutes no it's
been like three four I think four if you
go 10 minutes you're powerful all right
so I'll tell you powerful that's right
I'm one of the most powerful men ever I
told AOC she has a big booty that means
all the power that I need yes
I gotta read more Super jazz
all right don't die dick and balls says
great name yeah I enlisted in the US
Army in 2005 it paid E1 privates 1200 a
month how sad American treats it's so
America treated soldiers and vets just
get some food stamps bro quit
complaining man camera go get some food
stamps come back from the dead to to
tell you to get food stamps
I think that's a well doesn't say you
can't do that actually okay yeah the
rules that you couldn't eat are drinking
off it burns so yeah it didn't say
anything about it what about uh Tire
degreaser
it's graphene that's a little bit of
graphene I already have I already took
the vaccine so it's okay Alex oh take us
out there's a good one Eric Miller says
a black mermaid falls in love with a
rich white man in exchange for her right
to be a human she has to sacrifice her
voice if she wants to speak again she
has to seduce him to kiss her sounds
like a Disney movie um here we go
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats here Corn Pop he says welcome back
Luke well there you go I mean thanks for
having me it's good to be back I'm
having a lot of fun here it's awesome
[Laughter]
I'm contacting my lawyer I signed away
protect you from Indemnity I wasn't even
the members of all these things I
wouldn't want to be anywhere else in the
world but here right now very happy
all right let's say uh dime Kang says
Facebook is issuing warnings on people's
accounts for sharing Freedom Tunes
newest Jordan Peterson video saying it
violated their Community guidelines
regarding hate speech shout out to our
favorite big booty man Alex
yeah I have my
assistant
uh Freedom Tunes put out a couple of
really funny ones they put out uh if
Jordan Pearson really wasn't in cell and
it's really funny it's him when he I
don't want to give away the jokes it's
just really funny and then he did fixing
leftist memes again we got a shout out
because they were like they were like
homophobe Sheamus did an episode of Tim
cast like did an episode I was co-hosted
that show for seven months oh my mouth
my mouth is like it's like no man I know
it feels like I've used the 100 and
to your right bro Alex Alex
is dead did he just take a dump no I'm
just trying to just the pain
no my brain is now normal you seem like
you're actually getting better no it
feels good honestly the pain I like it I
have a BDSM uh fetish so I need this
that's why I like Kamala Harris so much
because she punishes me so bad it feels
good all right Alex all right oh wait
wait here's a good one Julie girl 1313
says just saw Katie Hobbs commercial
bashing Carrie Lake on your show we made
it
we're big fans and uh Katie Hobbs using
our show in a commercial wow okay you
know thanks for your money
well they didn't pay us they just used
it
it's funny when people are like can we
use a clip from your show and I'm like
in what context and they're like we're
commenting on it for a news video and
I'm like are you joking that's illegal
it's fair use you're gonna ask me people
take my videos all the time and just you
know whatever well but have you guys
seen the internet drama between who are
these podcasts and Stuttering John I
know that's kind of the niche but no
basically he he's like trying to fake
sue them because they use his content
for compare but as long as it's
transformed you know transformational
you can do that so for the people
playing at home if you watch somebody
you can react to it that's why reaction
content is so big I can't barely speak
to my math it feels like it's a little
bit are you giving up you're gonna drink
no how many minutes are it I'm never
giving up I'm never quitting dead cringe
up sorry none of you guys
you can until you kill me oh you need
milk I need some milk yeah but you were
getting some milk right now I I told I
told Chris to get money breast milk
correct I only drink listen listen it
says you can't eat or drink for an hour
to be invincible
you know I did say that I haven't you
know you're two minutes away from being
able to drink and being powerful okay
just two more minutes okay I feel like I
just had an abortion in my mouth so
unless you're allowed to say that on
YouTube no I'm pro-abortion so you're
allowed to say that
let's see
uh where are we at
waffle Sensei says you have to engage
with them no matter how culty they are
it's not about changing the cultist
minds it's about allowing normal people
to see what a conversation looks like
between a knowledgeable person and a
cultist we have milk
oh my gosh how much time wait wait wait
don't drink it just wait where did that
milk come from I don't know probably my
personal stash Luke's personal stash
well we know a baby formula there's a
baby formula one more one more minute
just to be sure because I think stuff
right there I think it's one more minute
that's some non-statist milk I'll just
tell you this much Nancy Pelosi's breast
milk is what this is
what the ice cream is 500.
why did you make me have a big pool
right now ankle now that's healthy what
are you talking about she's solving the
formula crisis herself thank you Alex
I'm not doing well I mean all right
you're good all right that's it 10
minutes you're powerful don't throw up
wait you don't just drink it you gotta
like swish it around a little bit
because what happens is the the oils the
oils get all over and the milk and the
fat and the calcium it helps it is
helping yeah it is immediately helping
yeah but you gotta like swish it around
oh man I'm a pimp on a blimp you gave me
the Pocky uh chip challenge and I grind
and shine because there's no amount of
food if this is an unlimited shrimp
Buffet I could do it if it was an
unlimited anything Buffet if you put
food in front of me I am like a dog and
you know why it's because when my
parents got divorced him they actually
fought for custody of our family dog
more than me so I was technically raised
by he would go with me on the weekends
wherever I went so I was with my German
Shepherd of Primo more than my parents
so that's why I'm an animal oh wait I
made a mistake
it's only been nine minutes
[Laughter]
because we're gonna make a segment you
know a special the Pocky pimpy segment
the Pocky pimp yeah yeah I love it
that's the one chip challenge and he
succeeds yeah we'll make it a short and
we'll put it up well and uh and to be
fair I actually took the and I don't
want to give them a BW threes or
whatever they have the hottest spicy
wing challenge and Tim I didn't want to
give you the inside baseball I actually
ate that and survived so I have a spice
level unlike anything you've ever seen
so that's why I like my Latinas like AOC
big booty spicy life
all right Tim didn't like that one uh
I'm trying to screen some of these
superchargers ah it's hot though it
still burns like you know I feel better
I mean I guess I feel better but my
mouth does my lips feel numb like
like I've been chewing on gasoline or
something all right Michael Morgan says
thoughts on Democrats investing 30 times
as much money on Trump supporting Maga
candidates so it's easier to run against
them than other candidates yeah that's
really funny because now they're going
on Twitter and they're being like Oh no
they're winning and it's like bro you
paid for him to win like there was like
three million dollars in endorsements
too in New Hampshire
yep and it was eight states 19 million
dollars total according to watch to The
Washington Post that they invested in uh
mainly Maga Republicans to run during
these primaries
yeah I mean it's hard to make a really
good point but that's also weird how
they've been the Democrats have been
voting in the Republican primaries to
get the candidate so not just the money
but they're actually voting on him
absolutely seems like it should be
illegal well I actually kind of like let
me tell you something this all right
let's see if it's the most Fair election
ever so nothing well here's gonna happen
we're gonna we're gonna go to this um
members only members only show so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
to watch it you can follow the show at
timcast.com you can follow me at timcast
um I just do you want to shout anything
out I don't know yeah yeah absolutely uh
Ryan Walters for oklahoma.com we're
trying to make sure that left-wing
indoctrinations out of our schools we've
seen Ron desantas Governor said in
Oklahoma be leaders on keeping the state
open fighting back on fauci and and the
coveted craziness but we want to be the
leader in education to show how you beat
back the left-wing teachers union get
them out of our schools and get all that
nonsense out so yeah please give me a
follow there on on all those channels as
well
and then Alex might make it to the maybe
after show I just want to say uh
congratulations to my wife and her
boyfriend Daryl uh she recently got her
pregnant so that's so I just
congratulations to you two uh and other
than that no uh you know you can follow
me outside 99 uh my mouth hurts um
that's about it thank you guys I'm gonna
I'm gonna give you some charcoal and
colostrum after this show to help
hopefully help you with the mud butt but
anyway my name is lucrative we are
change.org my YouTube channel
youtube.com we are change I'm only a few
hundred people away from 800 000
subscribers check out the page um there
we have a whole confrontation playlist
you can see a whole bunch of politicians
sweating up a storm youtube.com
I wanted to mention this yesterday
because you point out that you're you're
like deep person from Wikipedia yeah
wait wait you got you had your page and
they deleted it yeah because the
Washington Post called me Russian fake
news because I didn't believe in the
Russian hoax but this is this is this is
weird you've got like almost what 400
000 followers on Twitter or 300
something yeah yeah
Rolling Stone
opposed to New York Times multiple
mentions in on all the media
Publications time's over so so but
almost 800 000 YouTube followers yes and
like you you're not on like so well all
that has to happen is people who are
listening need to give Luke a Wikipedia
page yeah but they can delete it they
can make the page they depersoned me
there were special notes saying that if
he's a part of a news related event do
not mention him or his news organization
we are change because he's you know a
Russian disinformation according to the
Washington Post and their disinformation
so let's see if 35 000 people out of
honey of them listening right now and
out of the millions who listen are
interested enough to push back on the
lies from the corporate press and help
Luke out by getting his Wikipedia back I
never yeah yeah maybe I gotta balance
maybe you're better off with that one
because it'll just be full of lies
anyway yeah I don't care for it to be
honest with you you know what matters
most is people being on the website and
and being a part of the you know being a
part of this organization without uh big
Tech social media so you have your
platform timcast.com I have we are
change.org people could sign up on the
email list people could sign up on the
members area and they could we don't
have to go through big Tech social media
all their alternative design for your
website exactly and your website as well
so Alternatives uh independent of big
Tech social media is the future I'm
happy you're leading the way I'm doing
my best to do whatever I can we we
invented a zeppelin over here yeah yeah
you know we brought a guy and we put
Zeppelin and Wikipedia won't re-put in
that I invented a zeppelin I think it's
fake news anyway anyway sorry Lydia you
had yeah I am also here thank you guys
very much for tuning in this evening
this has been an incredibly entertaining
show with Alex I'm glad you enjoyed your
milk and that you survived and did not
throw up I'm gonna try to keep it so
that no one throws up on this show if
that's okay with everyone I feel like
that's for the best yeah you guys can
follow me on Twitter and minds.com at
Sour Patch let's as well as Sour Patch
lids.me we're gonna we're gonna go to
the members only show so make sure you
sign up at timcast.com and we'll see you
all over there in about an hour thanks
for hanging out bye guys